a
full council meeting on the 22nd of
february 2022
i have some items to depart to you
no fire alarm test is planned and should
the fire alarm sound please leave the
room at your nearest exit and meet at
the bottom of the car park
please raise your hand if you wish to
speak
and stay seated when speaking
please wait until a boom microphone is
brought to you insuring that you keep
your hand raised until the boom
microphone is brought over to you
you will not be heard on the live stream
otherwise
keep points short and i ask members not
to repeat points that have already been
raised
voting will be by a show of hands
except on the budget item which requires
a recorded vote
should the meeting be adjourned any
filming must cease
unless the express permission of those
being filmed has been obtained
iter agenda item seven future high
street newt nabba
when we go into part two the press and
public will have to need will need to
leave
once we go back into public session the
public will be called back into the
meeting the vote on the recommendation
will be taken in open session
right item one
could we have apologies for absence
please
gribble
haynes knuckle purser
morgan
jenks eden and parker khan
thank you
yes
noted
thank you very much now that we move on
to item two the the minutes
the minutes of the council on the 13th
of january 2022.
could i have a proposal please that
can you confirm what point of order
you're referring to cancer patch
sorry
right you are
okay
thank you chair
my point of order with regard to the
minutes refers to articles in the
constitution
3.3.5 and 3.3.3
3.3.5 concerning the appointments and
remuneration panel says that his role is
to make recommend make recommendations
to the council on various matters with
its remit 3.3.3
is quite clear the panel does not have
any decision-making powers being
advisory only and yet looking at the
minutes for item two announcements
paragraph three
if we look two-thirds of the way down
we're told that and this is with regard
to the complaint against mr woodhead the
panel unanimously determined that no
breach of the officer's code of conduct
had occurred surely given the
constitution um that that that was
misheard or misread that should be the
panel made a recommendation and that
recommendation should come to full
council
yeah just bear with me a minute
this was a disciplinary matter in
regarding a member of staff and does not
go to full council well according to
3.3.5 disciplinary matters do just for a
point of clarification um has mr
woodhead just advised you on this matter
i think it has
it's probably on record um
and i i must point out that i think he's
on very thin ice here because he is
advising on an item
so as to protect him
from the council scrutinizing a
complaint made against him
cancer patch i have a member wishing to
speak on the item if i could refer
cancer comic
thank you chairman i move that the
minutes are accepted and invited
yeah i think we're moving we're not
getting into a debate now councillor
patch so that
i'm amps
uh i don't think that's there that's
three so there was not a recorded vote
so uh it's been proposed by cancer conor
seconded by
cancer
gonna go to the vote please that we
accept the minutes all those in favor
against
abstentions
thank you very much
right i go to
some announcements now
councillors i would like to inform you
that i sent a letter to her imagine her
majesty the queen queen elizabeth ii
congratulating her on her platinum
platinum jubilee for 70 years service to
this country
i sent it on behalf of members employees
residents and of course myself so i just
think that was something we needed to do
and that has been done on behalf of the
council
also on the 23rd of march
there will be a covered memorial
tree planting in grounds of old fort
house
there'll be many invitees
and of course all councillors are
invited more details will come regarding
this but just give you prior notice on
the 23rd of march
in today's meeting there will be at
least one interval
it's most likely to be around the part
two items regarding the future high
street fund
just to give you prior notice that all
members of press and public will have to
leave the room at that time that's just
giving you
prior notice
one further item
members will recall that at the meeting
of the council held on the 30th of
november
councillor patch announced that he had
made an application to the judicial
review the council
i can confirm that the high court has
for the second and final time
refused permission
to digitally review the council and
ordered the councillor to pay the
council's costs
of
7811 pounds and 25 pence
thank you if we move on to item four
no there's no response that was just an
announcement we're not getting into a
council patch so please
there's no point at which point of order
are you referring to
there is no breach of the rules i'm
afraid can't
cancer patch i'm in announcements
there's no point of order in
announcements please
council patch
i'm gonna please
ask you to sit down please
i'm sorry council patch
please
could you please be silent councillor
patch
i am asking you to be silent counselor
patch
and not
going to say it again
can't recall it
chairman i move that on this matter
cancer patch be no further
[Music]
heard excuse the language please
there's a movement from a cancer patch
that from pensacon that cancer patch not
be heard any further do i have a second
on that cancer dewhurst
can i go to the vote on that matter
please that he not be heard any further
on this matter
any against
six
please could you refrain from losing
your hands when you're not in the
council to vote please not a member of
the council
abstentions
anybody abstained
thank you so cancer patch no further
comment on this matter please
right could we move on to
declarations of interest please
cancel wiggly
thank you chair i'd like to uh declare
that i am a director of the newton have
at cic appointed through this council to
that body i have no financial no
personal financial interest no pecuniary
interest in the matter and i intend to
speak and this is in relation to the
future high streets fund item
thank you councillor wrigley
any other declarations of interest
councillor hook
thank you chair i'd also like to declare
an interest as a director of newtoni cic
but have no pecuniary interest
and
therefore
may well speak on future high street
funds issue thank you thank you cancer
clarence
uh thank you chairman in relation to the
questions that i've asked
i do declare that i do live in one of
the lower lying properties that has that
in the past and i say in the past i'm
talking about over 50 years ago has been
subject to flooding by uh excrete
excretement or whatever you like to call
it from the sewage system thank you
thank you council clarence no more
declarations or cancer doors at the back
please
rightly right beside you
hi there yes i've got a declaration of
interest uh
in relation to the future high street
fund i'll declare that i'm an owner of
two mid-scale entertainment venues and i
sat on the uh
cultural uh groups for the city of bath
and the city of brighton hove uh i don't
suppose that would preclude me from uh
entering into the debate but i just
wanted to put that on record thank you
thank you cancer dawson
no more declarations
fine thank you
if we can now move on to item five which
is the budget and council tax for 2022
23
i'd like to ask
the executive member for corporate
services council keeley here in the
front
to move the motion please
thank you mr chairman before i introduce
the budget i have a statement with
regards to the energy rebate
i have asked for further information on
how the grant is administered
unfortunately we are still awaiting the
guidance from government
so we are light on details
what we do know is that everyone living
in banned a to d properties will receive
a payment of 150 pounds
this is not a discount on the council
tax it is a direct payment into
customers bank accounts local
authorities will be expected to pay 150
pounds to everyone who pays their
council tax by direct debit and
therefore their bank account details are
already known
there will be
bless you
there will need to be a process to put
in place to capture these details in
order to make the payments
in that we will be writing to all those
that don't pay the council tax to ask
for their details their bank details
and there's a note to that as well
unoccupied properties will not qualify
for this payment
residents living in banned e to h
properties will still be able to claim
help if they need
it but we will not yet know how this
will work in practice
it's difficult to say anything
with any certainty until we get the
guidance
from government so i will keep
colleagues informed
on the budget colleagues
can i first pay tribute to our staff who
have contributed to the savings and
income generated made
especially our chief financial officer
martin flincroft and his team for
preparing the final
financial plan proposals 2022 to 23 to
2024 to 25 for your consideration
colleagues the journey so far we have
consulted with you on the initial budget
proposals in january full council and
very little very little financially has
changed
we have had four meetings with overview
and scrutiny one and two
sharing the final proposals with support
from both
we have had two executive meetings as
well as two town and parish meetings
culminating in a six-week public
consultation with team bridge residents
the results i can share now
of the survey we consulted the residents
of team bridge 57 agreed with increasing
the council tax
support for climate change was at 68
63 agreed with our housing proposals
78 agreed with supporting the economy
and jobs and 82 agreed with encouraging
businesses in our area
while 82 percent agreed with improving
better transport links
72 percent agreed with promoting health
and well-being
and finally only eight percent wanted
this administration to reduce our
services
so to be clear we are increasing the
council tax by five pound on a bandy
property which is 2.78
half the rate of inflation of which team
bridge share is 8.55
the lowest it has been and still lower
than the average of devon district
councils
colleagues i've had many emails and
conversations with councillors on the
details i'm pleased to say we are
listening and acting where we can
our priorities continue to be
of a climate change officer with
increased temporary resources
and enhanced planning enforcement
we have increased the provision in the
capital program for climate change
projects
as we call them green leaf projects
we have increased support for housing
including the team bridge 100 team
bridge council houses being built now
while backing business and bringing
people and organizations together for
local neighborhood planning
the future high street fund will deliver
on town centre investment in
infrastructure employment local jobs and
cycleways
making newton abbott a premier market
town the heart of team bridge
we have a decarbonization scheme for
fordhaus offices newton albert leisure
center broad meadow sports center and
tim mcleido
can i add as reported by my colleague
council jackie hook we are sorry to hear
that midas has now gone into
administration and recognize the impact
this will have on our local economy and
of course my just employment employees
and families
midas was the main contractor for our
work to decarbonize the council's
headquarters at fordhaus and we are
currently investigating the options
available to us to secure continuation
of this work and to progress it as
quickly as possible
the other decarbonizations work on
newton albert and broad mender leisure
centers and the timber slider are
unaffected by this work
in being delivered by other contractors
these priorities i have just listed are
in line with the survey results which
cambridge residents wish to see
investing on our district and
communities
we are paying off one million of our
pension deficit in 2022-23
to reduce ongoing contributions
we are providing temporary resources to
faster deliver the significant projects
and proposals identified and within the
capital program
service reviews and processes to
identify business and systems
improvements and development
this includes estate management
governance and communications
our reserves will be at 12.8
of the net revenue budget or just over
two million pounds
we have an infrastructure delivery plan
investing funding community in
infrastructure levy and external sources
where available
we have continued to lobby government
for funding as we face continue
reduction in new homes bonus other
central government funding reductions in
particular provisional assumptions for
business rates for future years and the
reset of the
baseline our ongoing budget gap is now
2.6 million pounds
rather than 2.7
20 24 25 with earmarked reserves
plugging the gap in the years up to 2024
which i've reported to previously is not
sustainable
i'm sure colleagues
that like mine your inbox and
conversations you have with your
residents highlight the concerns over
the cost of living crisis
looming for team bridge residents
whether it's energy bills the rise of
inflation or the increase in national
insurance
from central government hitting
employees and employers this council
we have been listening to those concerns
and working with my colleague councillor
martin wrigley we have revised proposals
regarding council funding for our
voluntary sector organizations which i
will set out for you now
firstly i thank overview and scrutiny
colleagues for their work
you have done on the voluntary sector
funded redistribution
i know we appreciate that review is
necessary but we all recognize that the
proposals would be especially
challenging for those organizations at
this current time
council wrigley and i therefore propose
to pause those recommendations
we have listened to your feedback along
with the concerns of the various groups
such as the system advice bureau team
bridge council for voluntary services
east team bridge community transport and
newton abbott community transport
we are recommending to councillors that
the council retains the equivalent
funding of the 2021 2022 for at least
the next two years so that those
organizations who provide support for
team bridge residents and their families
we also propose to retain the supportive
rent subsidy for timber shop mobility
and the meadow center timmouth the
brooklyn centre in newton abbott and
others to the 2021 22 subsidy for at
least the next two years
however the small grant to kander cove
will stop
in addition to support and assist very
low very local groups and organizations
we also propose to increase the
councillors community fund for each
councillor by two hundred pounds a year
to one thousand two hundred pounds from
april for the twenty twenty two twenty
three financial year
i hope colleagues will recommend will
welcome these new proposals as they
continue to support the district-wide
and local organizations
if i can add that all these changes are
budget neutral
we will also introduce a new two-year
pot of 40 000 pounds per annum for tidy
team bridge initiatives to improve
cleanliness for towns and parish
councils
colleagues this budget shows we are the
representatives of our communities and
are supporting the residents of team
bridge and their families listening and
acting
i therefore propose that this council
agrees that a
that the team british band d council tax
for 2022-23
is increased by 2.78
or 5 pound to the 185 pounds and 17
pence per annum
the general reserves are increased to
12.8 of the net revenue budget for the
2022 23 or just over 2 million
pounds
c
that 100 000 pounds of the general
reserve balance in any one year
continues to be available to the
executive to meet the unexpected
expenditure in addition to the agreed
revenue budget
d
all other decisions with regard to
budgetary changes will be approved by
reference to vehement rules in the
financial instructions
e
that the summary revenue budget of
2022-23
is 16.1 million as shown in appendix 4
in particular the revenue budget
includes assumptions of a two percent
pay
rise from the first of april twenty
twenty two revenue contributions to fund
capital continues to be suspended in the
medium term to protect the revenue
budget
voluntary grants are amended as detailed
at the 8th of feb executive minis
minute number 12 and adjusted in the
2022-23
by
vehement a tidy teambridge pot is
introduced for the
2022-23 at 40 000 pounds per annum for
two years
the council's community fund is
increased to 1 200 pounds each and
adjusted in the twenty twenty two twenty
three by vehement a payment of one
million pounds to reduce the pension
deficit
f
that fees and charges are approved as
shown summarized in appendix 6
g
that the capital program is shown in
appendix 7 is approved in particular
this includes increasing jobs and homes
through continuing support for housing
while backing business and encouraging
community-led
has begun on the team bridge 100
affordable housing project with a second
site in newton abbett nearing completion
an increased rent rented program across
urban and rural sites
has commenced and delivery will continue
over the next three years of the program
increased investment for capital change
projects following successful funding
bid for low carbon heating and energy
system improvements
schemes are underway at leisure sites
and council offices with further
provision under the carbon action plan
infrastructure delivery
investment contribution to improve
education transport link sports and open
spaces
regeneration investment including one
hotel in newton about funded mainly from
prudent borrowing the funding offer from
the government future high street fund
for grant of 9.2 million aimed at
improving town centers
was confirmed this will have a positive
impact on newton abbott and with a wider
team bridge economy co-funding including
sil
grants from other sources and prudent
borrowing
there is also an indicative provision
for employment site investment to be
funded through the prudent borrowing a
business case will be brought to members
for consideration once it's finalized
h that prudent indicators are noted and
the prudent limits approved all
as set out in appendix 10
i
that the updated treasury management
strategy
statement and authorizing lending list
are set out in appendix 11 is approved
together with a capital strategy in
appendix 11a
j
that each scheme will be considered on
its merits as explained at the end of
appendix 11 to decide the calculation of
minimum revenue provision for capital
expenditure in 2022 23
and finally k
that the council tax
res
resolutions are recommended in appendix
14 as approved
colleagues both myself
and martin flincroft our chief financial
officer are available to answer any
questions you have
mr chairman
could i come back at the end for a short
summary thank you mr chairman
thank you councilor kealing for that
comprehensive uh
introduction and subsequent
recommendation thank you very much do i
have a secretary for the proposal
councillor connect thank you very much
um i do intend to open this for debate
and i will firstly go to the leader of
the main opposition group councillor
clarence if he wishes to speak in the
meantime i know council mcgregor put his
hand up what is that an item on the
um you would like to debate
two things
okay
thank you chair um
just to to follow up on a couple of uh
positive points that counselor keeling
brought up in the um in the speech you
made uh the first is that it's pleasing
to see that we've got councillor
community fund growing again um you know
having taken a drop and making more
money available for community projects
across the district
um in in respect of that i noticed on
the last um
notification of what balances were there
that there was quite a number of uh
councillors hadn't actually touched any
element of their council community fund
and i was hoping to confirm today that
at no stage any balance left over from
this year's fund will be spent on any
um on any event or project that is known
to be heavy carbon producer for instance
tim with air show
um so like a commitment at least that we
will not spend um you know any balance
on on funding that that particular event
the second element um
is the council tech coming back to the
council tax point that councillor
cooling made right at the start and it's
refreshing to see that real efforts
being made to ensure that as many
residents get there 150 pounds as
possible
um there are a few um
um council tax bills that are
that fall outside of the a to d
e to h environment and therefore things
like annexes so where somebody has a
house with a a floor with a separate
kitchen uh they're charged as an nx and
it was just really to find out whether
any effort would be made to clarify that
point
thank
thank you country healing can you come
back on that
if it's not in the budget it's not going
to be paid so to the timoth air show um
that is not a a policy that this council
this administration would support
um and secondly um we're still waiting
for information on the council um rebate
um as such it's not a council tax rebate
sorry it is uh 150 pounds that is going
we have a discretionary fund
and we will look at all those um annexes
as you pointed out council mcgregor and
and when we get advice from government
we will follow up on that
thank you okay i'll now go to councillor
clarence who's right behind you he's the
leader of the main opposition group for
any comments
yeah thank you very much uh chairman yes
uh
through the
early process of the budget the overview
and scrutiny i didn't have really uh any
problem with an increase of
2.78 five pounds on a band-aid properly
given that uh
we've got i suppose to keep pace
uh uh with inflation to a
a degree
so from that perspective i didn't have
um too much problem uh with it and the
things that uh
we're doing uh it's interesting to note
that
um
other
parties that we level council tax money
for
that over the years that
we've we've represented in the past
about 11 of what is collected we're
often seen as a big bad wolf because we
collect the money or and team bridge
should be doing so much more but by and
large
uh we keep just nine percent of what is
is paid now
so by and large um with all that we do
in the locality the parks the beautiful
things that
team bridge own and try to maintain
um no problem at all so from that
perspective i think we give quite good
value for money
uh i'd just like to sort of move on to
uh
to other things really uh if i may
uh on it um
the uh
council tax of course brings us in more
revenue as we continue to grow
the the council tax brings in now 9.3
million which is up 6.6 well up 600 000
on what we got in last year
so it's not all bad when we build a few
more houses we get enough money in and
the other thing i'd like to make comment
in is the rate support the revenue
support grant which we keep putting into
our budget forecasts
uh i think i guess now it won't be long
before we uh drop that because we
haven't had a revenue support for uh
five years now this is the fifth budget
where the revenue support grant has sort
of gone in the figures at zero so we are
if you like standing on our own two feet
financially what what we generate
we have we spend as you can see in the
in the uh income
and expenditure
in the income and expenditure account of
the revenue budget
uh so you know i think we can be proud
of that really because
you know if we do get a rate support
grant
um
then you you could say well somebody has
to find that money the taxpayer in the
system somehow so you know we're doing i
would say quite well from that
respective and we have done for for
quite some considerable time
uh under the the two uh
um if you like parties in the past that
have controlled this authority so
you know put the full marks to both i
would say
um what i would like to comment on the
capital uh side of things is i find
quite intriguing at times
this budget forecast of 2223
shows that we're probably intending to
borrow 5.4 million pounds
and yet we somehow managed to balance
the books every year not to borrow money
and if you look back
at the previous budgets
the 21 22 forecasts we anticipated
borrowing
17.9 million in the 2021 budget we
anticipated borrowing 14.6 million
in the 1920
uh budget we anticipated borrowing 7.4
million in the 1819 budget we envisioned
borrowing
23.6 million and in the 1718 budget we
envisioned borrowing 28.7 million and
yet we've never borrowed a penny if you
add if you add all those total um
borrowings up
that would that and we had to do what we
forecast
we would have in fact borrowed
97.6 million pounds and yet we haven't
borrowed a penny so
i've got to say full marks to martin and
his team
uh with this anticipated borrowing in
his budget forecast that we've managed
to keep in the black if you like and
what have you it could be construed as
sort of to a certain degree i feel uh
i'll try and uh put an analogy on it
a weather forecast in saying it's going
to rain all the time when things have
actually been a little bit sunnier and
not rain so full marks full marks to
martin for jiggling the stuff around and
we haven't gone into to any any debtors
on authority
so
it's interesting to note too
that more locally that other things is
that town and parish councils do
increase their budgets a little bit more
we haven't been capped and stopped from
doing this and we are indeed taking on
more and more uh
if you like responsibilities trying to
alleviate the district council uh of
charges on on what we own i'll give you
just one example for example
on this
the
local authority is responsible for my
nest tunnel at sheldon for example it
badly needs maintenance on it if you go
down that tunnel it's it's a shocking
mess and benevolently a local person has
walked down the tunnel and he says well
i'll pay for this to be squared up he
said i enjoy the village and what have
you and what have you and he's paying
2000 anonymous benefactor paying 2 600
pounds to the parish council to organize
cleaning up an asset of tdc so i think
this sort of thing is very commendable
and i do urge if there are any rich
benefactors around that feel they'd like
to pay towards any team bridge asset
when it's looking a little bit sorry for
itself why not thank you very much for
your contribution to society in doing
this so but overall i'll finish by
saying i commend this
what you've done in keeping the council
taxed down to the level that you have in
in what it's called fairly difficult
times thank you jim
thank you councillor clients uh is there
any wish to come back councillor keeling
or
mr flickroff
no all right with cancer connect
thank you chairman i'm grateful to
clarence for what he said it's true that
we haven't had a great support grant
from government for many years now the
council is increasingly reliant on its
own resources so there are some
difficult decisions in today's budget
for example
car parking is one of our biggest
generators of income and we've had to
review our car park so members will know
that in today's decision there are some
choices around introducing charges in a
couple of car parks that were previously
free or free up to now and also
extending charging for those small
number of car parks where it was
seasonal and we're running them
over the year um as councillor keeling
said we do need to balance uh the budget
in transition 84-25 there's currently a
2.6 million uh shortfall in there
and it's worth uh councillors just being
aware that we've commissioned um
a firm called ignite to work with the
management team to review how we provide
and align our staff and financial
resources uh with the council plan and
those priorities the work is uh
initially to develop a new target sort
of operating model for the council
along with a business case for change
and that's going to come back to council
for consideration in the summer
but it's all part of how we balance the
books and make that saving of 2.6
million but also how we modernize the
council so we look at improved digital
working
economies of scale how we improve our
customer services align our staffing
with the services that we provide so in
time that's going to come back i just
really wanted to share with all
colleagues so you know it's not just
about today's budget but it's budgets to
come and there is work ongoing on that
and i formally second the
budget proposals thank you chairman
thank you councillor connect uh i have a
hand raised to the back councillor doors
hi uh thank you uh i've got two points i
only have one point but i did want to
pick up on the very good point that
councilman mcgregor made which uh i'm
not sure was answered properly uh in
terms of the
use of counsellor funds for
uh high carbon uh initiatives or
projects for instance the the air show
so i'd seek further clarification from
councillor keeling that if a councillor
put forward
is my microphone on if they put forward
their support for the the air show as
part of their council of fund whether
that would or wouldn't be passed uh and
funding supplied by tdc for the air show
but that that wasn't actually my point
my point was uh in relation to midas and
the very sad demise of the company and
of course uh we've got grave concerns
for the employees for the customers for
the creditors uh of of midas and uh the
council is
a customer and one might imagine a
creditor uh of midas what i would like
to know is what the financial impact
of that uh is if it is indeed known yet
what due diligence was undertaken prior
to engaging midas what the overall
budget cost is and how much has been
spent how much work has been done and
how much work remains to be done and
whether any personal interests or
pecuniary interests led by anyone within
the council in relation to midas
at any point during the contractual
tender thank you
thank you councillor dawes
i believe councillor connie wanted to
come back on one of those points
thank you chairman i'll pick the easier
one which is the air show issue
council mcgregor and councillor dawes
the council would not wish to grant aid
an air show in the district um
if it was a request to the council for a
grant
in terms of the council's community fund
very generally there have been some like
touch rules around that and i don't
think at the moment
that if an individual councillor wanted
to use their accounts as community fund
for the air show there would be anything
that necessarily stopped them but i draw
a distinction there is a difference for
example with someone saying would you
support a grant say for the um to
actually get the aeroplanes here if
there was a contribution that had to be
made to the organizers as opposed to for
example a grant
for
volunteers to wear
litter picking out you know and go
litter picking so i think it would
depend on what was asked i think as you
raise it if that is a concern it might
be something that over in scrutiny
should quickly review to see whether
there is a
framework that ought to go around the
council's community funds so that any
money is spent it meets the council's
objectives and isn't spent in an
inappropriate way the checks that we
have on it at the moment are about how
counselors wish to use their grants and
their areas and obviously it comes into
the office um for a final approval as it
were
but um
i'm very open to the idea that between
us uh scrutiny may wish to evaluate and
see whether there ought to be some
further limitations on how the grants
are used
i hope that's helpful with regard to my
just i'll have to hand over to
martin flitcroft
and i know there was something in the
member's newsletter a week or so ago but
it may not be as detailed as the
questions counselor daughters asked
mr
flickcroft
yeah i don't know the answers to all the
questions that you've raised but in
terms of our contract with midas
we looked very hard
at the financial position of midas
before we engaged with them
we'd only
engaged to do some initial works so our
exposure is
very low at the moment very initial
works were the only monies that we that
we're going to have to pay out for the
main contract itself hadn't been signed
and we were looking to create a bond to
ensure ourselves against any issues such
as has come forward and we didn't get to
that position so
we're in a re-procurement position now
so i think what that will mean is it
will delay
the the works going on by eight nine ten
eleven weeks perhaps something like that
but that's as far as as i know at the
moment that that works on going
happy with that cancer doors
okay uh councillor russell
um thank you chairman well councillor
conrad has really raised the question of
the air show and given explanations as
to why this council is not going to
support i wonder if that that
explanation and the details could be uh
given to the air show committee so that
they know exactly where the council is
standing on this one because it's not
just the show it's the safety
precautions around it and everything
else and whether the council might be
prepared to contribute to something
along those lines rather than the planes
flying in the air because i think it's
intended that the air show will go ahead
but it would be nice to feel that it
went ahead uh with some support from
this council because it is a big draw
for crowds to come in and it's it's uh
it's two years since we had the last one
which was very successful so i'd just
like to just think about it and think
about the effect that
this support from this council would
have on the committee and they would be
very pleased to perhaps discuss the
proposals directly with a representative
from this council thank
thank you councillor russell um
councillor phipps
can i ask you to keep your hand raised
so that the uh the boom operators know
where you are
thank you thank you mr chairman um first
i'd like to declare an interest because
i am the vice chairman of the air show
committee
and um i also just like to
say that i have spent all my counsellor
funds
and not one penny of it on towards the
air show and i just hope that
other councillors when they do their
counselor funds they have some um
thought as to where they're putting
their money and to the green credentials
of all other
aspects as well because it's it's okay
saying that the air show is not green
but you know where is your money going
to and please be careful or you're
spending it because they might not be
going to a green project
so there should be something put in
place to
some scrutiny to see whether
counselors funds are being spent
correctly thank you
thank you councillor phipps i don't know
if anyone would like to come back on
that at all
councillor mcgregor was first
hand
thank you chair it was just to clarify i
was talking about the balance of funds
that were left over from this year so
any council hadn't spent
or hadn't allocated any of their
community fund this year
um if it was carried forward there'd be
a there would be a pot like there was in
2019 20 2021 so on um so it's just
really to clarify that
that fund wouldn't be then just
dispersed um
you know as grants to various elements
without being checked for their green
credentials and it wasn't just the air
show it was other carbon heavy projects
that were that i was
referencing the air show being an
example of one
um in terms of individual uh councillors
and and their community funds going
forward of course you know councillors
would want to
support their communities so there is no
problem with that their community fund
is theirs to disperse as they see fit
and i do welcome uh councillor connor's
suggestion that perhaps we look at a
framework for allocation of funds in
future to ensure as councillor phipps
has said that they're going to the
greenest options possible in in line
with this council's commitment to
climate change emergency
thank you councillor mcgregor i think
councillor connect wanted to answer that
um
partly
thanks jim so just on the issue of any
unspent funds previously of course money
was taken to support community work
during kovid i'd encourage all
councillors to try and use their budget
this year before uh the end of the
financial year i recall from the members
newsletter uh final application dates is
the 13th of march
the intention is any unspent money will
be withdrawn and put back into the
council's coffers as part of the
balanced budget at the end of the year
so it won't be available to go anywhere
else whatever the application is you
know so spend it in your local community
is the message
thank you council connect cancer doors
you want to come back
yes thank you you did ask if i was happy
with the answer from uh martin flickroft
a minute ago and uh
as martin pointed out he didn't answer
many of my questions so i just asked if
there's the potential to uh
to give more detail on the exact
financial exposure to midas to share
what due diligence was done before the
uh before the contract was entered
and uh and also uh to share if any
declarations of interests were were ever
given uh and i'd also like to come back
on on on the air show as well because
that it was noted that we should think
about the impacts of not having the air
show uh i'm personally thinking about
the impacts of the last three storms
over the last weekend and the impacts of
climate change uh and i think they
should be at the forefront of our mind
thank you
thank you councillor kanga council doors
mr fitcroft would you like to answer any
of
yeah we can look at that please
that you've raised and we'll probably
put something in next monday's
newsletter to cover those points
thank you very much councillor kurzweil
you chairman um i don't know whether any
other counsellor in this room has the
same experience with me as me
but at the moment i cannot find out how
much i have left in my community fund
one of the officers sent through
a a
piece to our town clerk to say that i
had all my money left in well i know i
haven't but i cannot
manage to find how much i have left
and i need this money now
to spend before april and i would be
very grateful if i could have my
up-to-date balance please
thank you
council wrigley
uh the the up-to-date balance is
currently on the website
council hooked you the answer to that
question
councillor hook
stand up
thanks chair no it wasn't on that
question i wanted to go back to the
question of carbon carbon heavy um
events
within our district
and i would work on a piece of work by
overview and scrutiny on the topic
because i have raised it more generally
the air show of course is just one
specific example of a of an event that
has a high carbon footprint which i
personally would not like to see taking
place in our district and the council
has not supported it directly but of
course that's just one example and the
council
owns a fair number of properties and
pieces of land that it leases out or
hires out to groups for events etcetera
that's a big piece of work to start
monitoring
the
use of all of those
and
ask questions about the carbon footprint
of what goes on there
it could be considered very onerous
there might be questions about what
other factors should we consider when
people hire or lease our property it's a
big piece of work but i personally would
like to see
some work started on that because i
think it is important that we're not
even seen to be indirectly supporting
some activities such as high carbon
activities um so i would welcome that
piece of work um starting i have
inquired um as to what other councils
are doing on this and it's a difficult
one there aren't many councils that have
policies and criteria in place because
as you'll understand it's not an easy
topic to start
controlling the um every single event
and
activity that happens in our leased
property and land thank you
thank you council hook um councillor
kuraswa we will we note your comments
and we will get back with response to
you as to what your fund is or a way of
way of finding that out thank you
um i don't see any other hands up as a
question so i will come back to cancer
keeling for summing up on the budget
recommendation
thank you mr chairman
i'll be brief
colleagues the debate has been helpful
this budget for team bridge has come at
a time with many uncertainties kovi's
restrictions being relaxed and the
government funding reducing year in year
out with short-term fixes
we will continue to lobby government as
i have said for the medium and long-term
solutions
we have listened to you in this process
and our communities including especially
our voluntary groups
who are needed more than ever entering
this cost of living crisis
we have put in place vital funding
lifelines to help those most vulnerable
colleagues this budget is set out before
you and i hope you will support it thank
you mr chairman
thank you very much uh cancer keeling so
that was your proposal recommendation
and second invite counselor gone it we
now need to go to the vote and it's
going to be a roll cover call vote so
i'll ask sarah to do the roll call vote
please
that's a culture
that's the connect
council of cook
[Music]
councillor d cox
cancer h [ __ ]
that's the doors
that's the dewhurst
that's the fodon
chancellor goodman bradbury
that's the hayes
councillor hawking
against the gordon hook
also jackie hook
counselor jeffrey yeah
so i didn't hear that
thank you
councillor jeffreys
council keeling
councillor kurzweil
councillor mcgregor
councillor malone
that's so nutley
that's little
that's a patch
council pierce
that's a john petherick
councillor linda pederick
that's a phipps
pencil rolison
councillor russell
got some wiggly
thank you very much cancer keeling
that's carried
right well now move on to the next item
on the agenda and it is public questions
we have a number of questions here um
and i will start with
if she's here
lisa goody
gowdy i do apologize
is she here
thank you you've you've asked questions
and you've had written answers can i
have one supplementary for each question
related to
the question
thank you
sorry what
okay
it's not as no please let's
go
please
no you can you can leave the paper we
don't want any any speech or anything
please just just leave it with us
please i'm
not allowing this i'm going to ask you
please to refrain
i'm waiting for lisa goody please please
i'm going to ask you again
you're please i'm going to ask
if you do not
security to remove you please
i have
please i'm asking you to stop once again
or i will ask security to move you
we'll take that and we're going to
adjourn the meeting at this time thank
you that mating is adjourned
requirement
you are therefore responsible for
executing decision making at a local
level
the government themselves had eased on
lockdown restrictions
but the council chose to
prolong regulations at the detriment of
people's lives and earnings
doesn't this therefore contradict the
answer that council has given
if there is no signatory contract with
councils under the public
could an individual resident in this
case choose to pay for which services
the council provides
we are entitled to know in detail
what funds are allocated for especially
since a huge amount of money was saved
for services unable to be accessed
during lockdown
thank you very much point of order can't
cancer doors
i don't believe we're being streamed at
the moment yes we are
oh well that's not what the public are
telling me
okay
okay
okay
can you confirm it started at the uh the
question
you can't confirm that
oh well i would suggest that the
supplementary is restated so it is
matter of public record no no no we
we've gone through that and
we'll carry on um
the supplementary question i mean
constant cancer connect can you
in the front cancer connect we'll reply
to that
thank you very much for the
supplementary in terms of the first part
i believe the council has acted
appropriately i don't believe we've done
anything that we should not have done or
weren't permitted to do in relation to
the idea or concept of a council council
tax contract there is no such thing as a
contract that i'm aware of
but rather like income tax we pay
our share and we're probably paying for
services that some of us may not wish or
may not use so there'll be some people
for example who pay uh council tax to
the elementary county council who don't
use the library service but it's
provided we don't use a youth service
but it's provided and so it is with all
services
members of the public who are
required to pay council trusts can't
pick and choose which services they are
funding or not funding you pay the
council tax as a whole for the level of
services that are provided by the
council and as we've just for example
gone through the budget and approved the
budget that sets out how the council
will be using its resources next year
thank you chairman
thank you councillor connor um if you
you have a second question would you
have had a supplementary which you've
had a written answer to have you got a
supplementary for your second question
was that inclusive
councils are responsible for a duty of
care why did you not take into
consideration the vital aspect of
freedom of information facts
to carelessly spend out on fear
propaganda poses etcetera in public
places
how much of the financial resources have
really been wasted
there really is no excuse for councils
to display the height of ignorance
leading to crimes against humanity
[Music]
chairman i don't accept for one second
that the council has been responsible
for crimes against humanity the council
has provided facilities to the nhs in
order to provide a vaccination program
members of the public are being able to
choose whether they have a vaccination
or vaccinated or not that's a matter for
them i think the council has been part
of the national recovery of a good and
solid vaccination program people have a
choice whether vaccinated or not i
respect the choice of those who choose
not to be vaccinated i don't respect
their decision to try and
instigate a campaign against the council
when what it's done is right for the
public as a whole thank you chairman
thank you cancer connect and do you have
a supplementary for your third question
lisa
um
i still there still hasn't been any
confirmation as to why you haven't
checked the data i.e freedom of
information
could you elaborate a little bit on that
the justification of freedom of
information
that um
[Music]
yeah to justify the decision of why
um the public haven't been
well informed about the actual facts
from freedom of information that surely
is the first thing you would do as a
council
to represent the public
kentucky
chairman the freedom of information that
provides the ability for people to write
questions to the council to accounting
for the public organizations and require
information so so that's there and
available at the council as i've
outlined both in responses to these
questions and previously is advised by
government the nhs as professionals that
we rely on it's within their competence
and professionalism to advise uh what we
have done generally is to provide
facilities where the vaccination program
has been undertaken
and supported the nhs and our hard
working staff in nhs in so doing i don't
think there is anything for the council
to consider
in terms of detriment to its behavior in
fact i think we are part of an exemplary
national program to ensure that those
who wish to be vaccinated are
and the nhs provides the information and
people will satisfy themselves or not as
to whether they wish to be vaccinated as
an individual choice thank you chairman
thank you councillor connect
we now move on to the second questioner
i don't know if there is a
representative from the newton abbott
and district civic society here
i will take that as no no one is
standing up we didn't believe anyone's
coming so yes we will move on to there
was going to be three questions they've
had written answers so we'll now move on
to the next questioner amy hedger is amy
here we hadn't had confirmation that
she's here
so once again she's had written answers
so there's no supplementary she's not
present
we'll now move on to mr john pike
director of the new nurbur community
interest company who has three questions
i understand he's here
have you got a supplementary to your
first question mr pike
thank you mr chairman i do have one
supplementary
my name is john pike i'm vice chair of
newton abbott cic
thank you for your responses
i am not suggesting that the council
should speculate on what the position of
historic england and the theater's trust
might be
what i'm suggesting is would not be wise
for the council to find out as soon as
possible what is the position of
historic england and the theatre's trust
on the loss of the grade 2 listed
theater
so the council can take up the offer of
newton abbott cic to collaborate on
amending these unfortunate proposals by
restoring the theater before it is too
late
councillor jefferies
if you could put your hand up so they
know where you are
cancer jefferies
thank you john thanks for your question
uh i'll be referring to some of this in
my um introduction
in the next phase so if it's all right
for
everybody to wait until then
is that okay with you mr bike thank you
so you have the second question and you
have a supplementary for that
no no supplementary for that and once
again your third question supplement not
for that also that i presume that will
be covered also
thank you um we move on to the next
questionnaire sarah mallett is sarah
mallett here we've not had confirmation
so it doesn't look as if she's here so
she's had a written answer to her
question so we'll move on now
and this is to
mr richard ward friends of the alexander
theatre you have two questions um do you
have a supplementary for your first
question yes i do thank you mr chairman
thank you for your responses
my name is richard ward i'm chairman of
the newton happened in district musical
comedy society and also a member of the
phot committee
my first uh response to my first
question
uh answers in a way the um the question
put to me by by the council's own uh
reply
um
which was to which evidence gathered
does this refer
the overwhelming evidence came partly
from the zoom meeting facilitated by
quarterbridge in which a considerable
number of the attendees stated clearly
that an open space
in there provided in their plans would
not work for them
and at the cic meeting last tuesday
several
arts and entertainment groups who had
not been consulted
said it would be completely inadequate
for their needs
and what i need to hear really is
whether they these bodies who do matter
because they are the people who will use
the space intended whether they will be
indeed consulted at some point thank
thank you cancer jefferies
all right thank you thank you richard um
again i'm going to be covering this in
in my introduction and in the next point
on the agenda so if it's okay to leave
it till then
would that be okay with you mr ward
that's fine and regarding your second
question do you have a supplementary for
that yes i do
thank you
um the second question is relating to
the business case that photo have tried
to produce
the question is is the procedure
outlined in the council's response
strictly consistent with the procedure
adopted by the future high street fund
for amendments to bid schemes thank you
council jeffries
thanks
thank you for that interesting question
and can i refer that to one of the
officers if that's okay
um
is there anyone available to give that
answer from the officers
neil blaney
thank you um there isn't a set process
as such for exam amendments to the
scheme there are requests
or
messages sent out from future high
street funds when for example
we were successful with the bid
asking us to go through a process to
review
any updates we were asked to look at the
impact of covert as part of it and again
that comes directly from if there was a
requirement to go back and look at the
um
the change the proposals are submitted
then that would be in consultation with
the future high street fund but the
process we've set out is the process
that the council went through to
secure the funding in the first place
uh and the response i think picks up the
fact that
um what's being proposed is taken taken
apart a fundamental part of that
submission
which would require a complete review of
the whole business case for the market
hall so you wouldn't just look at the
theater on its own you'd need to look
completely again at what was being
proposed for the market hall space as
well
thank you mr delaney
okay we'll move on to our final
questionnaire if she's here veronica
diggings her teachings
she here
i don't think she is so that's uh looks
to be the end of the public questions
thank you very much all members of the
public for that
i'd like to now
move on
to item seven
which is uh the future high street fund
for newton
market
um cancers before i ask councillor
jefferies
uh the executive member for economy jobs
to move the recommendation i'd like to
ask all of you when we get to the debate
on this to be clear concise and
respectful in all your comments
may i further remind you that there is a
part two to this item and that any conf
any comments referencing the
confidential session
must be restricted to the part two
period
when we move into that period and it
will be at that time that we'd take a
break when we move into that part two
situation
so i will now ask councillor jefferies
to outline
the recommendation thank you councillor
jeffries
thank you chair
um colleagues members of the public and
interested parties thank you for being
here today i'd also like to thank
everybody that's taken the time to write
to me i haven't been able to respond to
everyone
but i'm hoping you'll get some feedback
today
i'm introducing the budget budget report
for the market hall regeneration of
newton abbott
and i'm recommending that we approve the
budget outlined in part two of the
report to deliver the project detailed
in section four
i will further go through these
full points
later on a significant sum of 9.2
million pounds investment from
government through the future high
streets funds which is as hoped will
refresh and revitalize the town and
beyond
drawing in an increasing number of
people from surrounding areas and more
through tourism to shop and to socialize
and experience a vibrant bustling town
centre a premier market town to be proud
of
a package of almost 100 million pounds
investment through all of our programs
today is the convergence of 12 years of
outreach meetings consultations
refinements and seeking out financial
ways to bring those discussions into
reality
pre-submission public engagement surveys
resulted in 877 responses with more
recent stakeholder engagement sessions
involving 22 people from local
organizations and groups representative
of hundreds of their customers that's
thousands of people around the table if
we vote yesterday to accept the money in
terms of consultation it's important to
keep that dialogue going where it's
relevant and useful
the time scales are so short any
dialogue will need to be focused
the aim of the future high streets fund
is to renew and reshape town centres and
high streets in a way that drives growth
improves experience and ensures future
sustainability
it will do this by providing co-funding
to successful applicants
to support transformative and structural
changes to overcome challenges in their
area
there are challenges
the reality we live in we've heard today
from month to month
there is little certainty to plan for an
effective future
we face an uncertain economic time where
the high street has seen a huge decline
team bridge has some of the highest
levels of deprivation in the country
with people on this very day struggling
to make a choice between paying their
bills and feeding their families
many constituents tell me they're unable
to meet the rising costs of living that
they're worried about the impending
increases in utilities clothes household
items and groceries costing more
the average family will need to find an
extra fifteen hundred pounds per year
possibly more is predicted that even
then even those that are reasonably
comfortable up to now will feel the
pinch
so what responsibility does a district
authority have in exploring options to
offer businesses locally to thrive
businesses that help to bring the
quality of life into our town centres
the options are laid out in more detail
in the reports i have hoped you had a
chance to look at
there is do nothing that means nothing
changes
a standalone theatre which we've heard
from photo and seen in the questions
and approve the budget accept the
proposed scheme a combined multi-use
cultural space to re-establish the
markets at the heart of the community
offering mixed-use space providing
leisure dining shopping artistic
community and array of cultural
opportunities
economic impact assessments the world
over demonstrate that when empty units
in a town centre increase a gradual
decline takes place it's there for all
to see
and it is difficult to draw people back
in
communities that thrive do so where
there's a diverse offer to suit the
taste of many at the heart of this
meaningful consultation
in approving the budget for this project
today
if you choose to do so
there is an exciting opportunity for
everyone in the community from traders
whose businesses rely on the football
into town to creative industries
collaborating with each other to bring
this vision into reality
but the decision today rests on accept
or decline the offer of 9.2 million
pounds
i've received lots of emails asking what
the space will look like
there are sketches
and some have drawn this into long
discussions but in reality i can't tell
you i can't draw a comparison i can draw
a comparison with something easier to
visualize if you've worked on your own
home improvements
you'll know you can have an idea of what
will work you may even sketch it out but
you really won't know what will be
uncovered until you peel back the
wallpaper and probably half the wall
comes away with it
i can tell you
that the vision is to create an asset
for the whole community that functions
during the day and evening year round
the final scheme and finer points of the
designs fixtures and fittings have not
been made
we are committed to further engagement
being carried out and considered more as
part of the planning application
the next stages will include working up
of a detailed design allowing future
engagement to feed into the process
there are multiple elements to be
considered in how the final proposals
will work
currently the vision is to have a
dedicated role to promote the market and
facilitate performance arts and crafts
in the building
there are also specialists including an
acoustician appointed as part of the
design team who will be working with the
architect to ensure the details are
worked through
in gaining this successful offer from
the future high streets fund team bridge
district council should be proud
i've been in countless meetings over the
last two years with councils who have
not been so lucky whose bids although
they have been brilliant have not made
the mark
there is less investment on offer from
government and without approval today
the much needed regeneration into the
market quarter will not happen
and a bleep
outlook for our traders will continue
there are 40 market employees
plus others in the market at walk area
that will be negatively affected
if this vote does not go through
so what kind of future do you see
lost my space
for the traders in the market quarter
and the town centre of newton abbott
the vision is that the 9.2 million will
help restore newton abbott to the
premier market town it has historically
been
a thriving town with reinvigorated
bustling markets bijou stalls a
gastronomic experience with an
entertainment and cultural scene to
match
the process particularly around the
retention of the alex theater has
created lots of discussion we've heard
that today demonstrating how much the
people of newton abbot and beyond care
deeply about their heritage and have a
flair and passion for the arts culture
and regeneration i personally look
forward to more of these discussions to
help
transform the market quarter to help
make it appealing to a wider range of
people from across the district and more
profitable for those who choose to open
their businesses there
there is a fire in the belly of the
people of team bridge one that is future
focused and can be weaved through these
next stages of this regeneration if it's
accepted
the report is looking for members to
approve the budget in order to progress
the project the scheme was agreed in
principles subject to engagement and the
final business case in april 2021.
the report details the background and
steps taken following the approval
further engagement is proposed in the
next step section
part two of the report seeks to add
context to the current position of the
market both in financial and footfall
terms
in terms of strategic fit the linkages
are far-reaching there has been a wide
array of studies engagement and reports
on development plans for newton abbott
over the last 12 to 15 years
there are links to team bridge local
plan
2013-33 na8 and 9 focus on strengthening
the town center the team bridge 10 going
to town newton abbott master plan team
bridge covert recovery jobs plan are all
being supported by this scheme
as aforementioned the aim of the future
high streets fund is to renew and
reshape town centres and high streets in
a way that drives growth improves
experience and ensures future
sustainability
a requirement of the bid is that it
should have clear economic outputs i
mentioned earlier the context of the
uncertain future councils face in
finding money from government to achieve
growth
the funding aim of increasing footfall
data evening and introducing new uses
including street food food courts arts
community and culture meets these
criteria and ensured our success above
other less fortunate towns
it is important to note that a
refurbishment or redevelopment would not
meet that funding criteria
the project in its entirety looks at
regenerating the market hall in
alexandria
the creation of a news four screen
cinema
decking to qriket field road car park
queen street revitalization
and national cycle route
our future high streets application had
to meet the government appraisal and
evaluation
and included scaling back projects
undertaking a covert assessment
aforementioned and resubmitting the
application due to this scheme being
over-subscribed
council approved these amends in april
2021 subject to the final business
business case been ratified and future
stakeholder engagement
the successful funding award based on
the resubmission was amount announced in
may 2021
the report sets out the alternative
options considered in the preparation of
the recommendation
one is to do nothing which is elaborated
in part two and indicates the drop in
footfall and revenue pressure of the
current way the building performs
two is the standalone theater
the unviability of the fotap business
plan that was sent to councillors is in
the risk to the entire project and not
meeting the green book criteria
the plan only looks at the theater
not the entire bid
the friends plans require taxpayer
subsidy a minimum capital investment of
500 000 pounds a low rent and elements
of the building repair and maintenance
remaining
with team bridge district council
the latest set of plans being circulated
shows a new elaborate design which would
significantly increase the cost
with no increased income stream
identified
the proposed approach three sorry the
proposed approach knowledge acknowledges
the importance of performance base and
culture from fota and seeks to include
this in the plans it is accepted that
with option three there was an element
of compromise but it is realistic
affordable and deliverable and will mean
greater access to a space that currently
exists or would exist in the do nothing
scenario
the proposed scheme with a combined
space to re-establish the markets at the
heart of the community
offering a mixed use activities
providing leisure dining shopping
artistic community and cultural
opportunities are what is recommended to
go forward with today
as i bring this to a close
i urge you
to take the decision today based on the
needs of newton abbott remembering the
40 market employees and more that could
be negatively affected
i cannot imagine how the businesses are
feeling today knowing that their future
hangs in the balance
i'll be voting for accepting this money
today as despite my love for the arts
and background in it which has afforded
me a 25-year professional career i
cannot have on my conscience knowing
that i've made a decision that will
affect people's jobs homes and families
there's no point in having lots of new
housing roads built and expecting to
attract big companies in here to provide
better paid jobs if people don't want to
live here because there isn't a fit for
purpose heart of a town wouldn't you
rather your children stayed to build a
future rather than to move to big cities
like bristol and london
colleagues i asked you to vote thinking
of all aspects of what this 9.2 million
means and i move the report with the
following recommendations
that we approve the budget outlined in
part two of the report to deliver the
project detailed in section four
two to delegate authority to head of
place and commercial services in
consultation with the chief finance
officer and the portfolio holder for
economy and jobs to take such decisions
necessary to deliver the project
and three
as an amendment
that the council continues to engage and
consult with regard to the project
design and considers the interconnected
needs of the market and cultural hub
performance space
through a new steering group chaired by
the portfolio holder for economy and
jobs and that the council's appropriate
committees are regularly updated on
progress
thank you for listening
thank you councillor jefferies do i have
a second here for that please sir
councillor wrigley
uh cancer wrigley would like to speak
a point of order
okay
what's the point of order
it was
the
speech given by councillor jefferies
basically answered the question the
first question that
mr john pike a member of the public
mentioned are you going to afford him
the opportunity now to ask a supply
quest supplementary question
uh following that speech
that that was his supplementary question
i believe
yeah
are you happy with that mr point
yep he's happy okay
councillor wrigley
uh thank you councillor jeffries and
thanks to the officers and the team that
has brought all this forward to us and
thank you for adding the steering group
i think there's one thing we can all
agree on that the centre of newton
abbott is in need of some tlc
and that nine million will be a helpful
contribution to achieve that
i'm excited by the idea of a thriving
market want to rival tot ness one that
works with our local providers growers
crafts and trades people
drawing people in during the day from
across the district and operating
alongside and growing markets in tinmuth
or chudley or daulish
and i'm excited by the idea of a
thriving evening economy with cinema and
with a wide variety of live
entertainment
from orchestras to poetry from community
choirs to dances and from amateur
productions to professional touring
shows
i recall seeing the tempest by the rsc
in dualish with my children many years
ago but that was an all too rare event
i want to see quality performance most
nights of the year that brings people
into the center of newton abbott
in fact i want to see this creating a
cultural hub of the town and the
district
which brings us on to the details of the
paper in front of us
to me it's clear we should neither do
nothing nor opt for a solution that is
neither transformational nor sustainable
we need something that is more than just
a standalone theater
we need a revitalized market and a true
cultural hub that can support dancers
orchestras choirs professional
performers and even
stand-up comics
however what we have in front of us does
not detail the design nor the details of
the layout of the interior we have an
indicative layout that designates areas
within the building no more than that
how we choose to use those spaces and
what facilities or structures are within
them is not yet stated
and this is subject to further
consultation design prior to bringing
forward a planning application
and with that with the amended
recognition with the amended
recommendations i can see that the
proposed steering group can help us do
this and be key in that
but this is not a simple project and we
have a number of hurdles to get over
it is great that the fund is helping us
to finance a new cinema that will be a
good complementary attraction to the
cultural hub performance space for the
evening economy
and of course any changes to the
interior of the market hall in the alex
building will also be subject to listed
building consent and just because it's a
council project does not guarantee
planning consent
but here again i think the steering
group will be a key to making this
success
and we need to make sure that
performance space provided is not only
suitable and adequate but
transformational and sustainable
and for more than just theater
i'm expecting the steering role will
play a key role in getting this right
personally i don't know what it'll look
like exactly it may be a superior
version of the tin with pavilions
this has become a real draw for tynmouth
and in dualish i often hear it praised
and spoken about it is a multi-use
compromise but it does provide more than
just theater and appears to succeed in
drawing football to the area
or it may be more efficient and
effective to look at the designs brought
forward through the newton at cic to
expand and enhance the current
structures to create a space suitable
for larger audiences and different types
of performance and linking them to the
revised market hall
however it cannot be less than
transformational and it must be
sustainable
it will need good professional
management to ensure that whatever is
provided
is almost constantly in use and
maximizes the audiences
and it must be suitable for a wide range
of groups in the town and surrounds to
use
i thank the newton hub at cic for
drawing together a meeting of some 25
local culture organizations and hearing
what facilities they will be able to
make good use of in the performance
space
and i thank those organizations or many
of those organizations for the letters
and emails
telling us what they will need and we
should cater to this range of
organizations
as much their needs as much as we can
and the steering group is key to this
and i expect to see the cic having a
strong voice in this
the success on the mark of the market
will rely on
will rely on it having a clear identity
and purpose
some star attractions strong marketing
and cooperation neighboring towns
it must be a rival to the other big
markets especially tottenham
bring people in during the day
fixing up the building is necessary but
not sufficient
developing how the market will operate
will take time and we need to ensure
that we regenerate in that aspect as
well
the combination of the significant
entertainment space to drive the evening
economy and the enhanced market to drive
daytime economy is compelling and the
two must work together to get the
required cross-fertilization of visitors
and this all points to a professional
management of the entertainment space
and related but distinct management of
the market space this should create a
synergistic boost to trade for all
so i think this is not an easy project
and i thank the teams for bringing it
forward and getting funding
this is a project that newton abbott and
wider team bridge stand to gain a lot
from
and i'm happy that we need to progress
with a regeneration for the area i am
happy to do this using central
government funds
we have yet to determine the detailed
design it's vital that we involve a full
breadth of vision for the evening
economy and the daytime economy and
setting out that design and the amended
proposal involving the steering group
should help us get that right
so i'm very happy to second this
proposal as amended thank you
thank you councillor
i have a couple of hands up so i'll next
go to uh councillor dawes
hi thank you for the
the
ability to speak on this matter uh i've
read through the uh the amount of uh
detail that was provided in both part
one and part two
uh of of this
of this very important issue
uh i was very disappointed and surprised
to find that a letter from the theater's
trust has not been disclosed
to members um that has been sent last
thursday by the theaters trust if people
don't know who the theists trust are
they are a statutory body who need to be
consulted uh on any changes to theaters
throughout the country and their
their weight has uh
their influence has a great deal of
weight on any planning decisions
since the letter has not been uh
disclosed to members the theater's trust
gave me the
opportunity and ability to reference it
and i will share with anyone who would
like to at the break a copy of this
letter
so from the theatre's trust letter the
council has not to date saw the
engagement of the trust on his plans for
the alexandra we're the national
advisory public body for theses and
significantly we are also a statutory
council tea in the planning system
the trust rema extends to theater
buildings in other uses nonetheless the
alexander alexandra has retained its
theatre and functionality and continues
with live performance
if the current plans are progressed
without compelling evidence and
justification for the loss of the
theater and performance provision we
would strongly be objecting to the
relevant planning application
we would note as a statutory council t
the council would need to demonstrate
cogent and compelling reasons for
departing from our expert view a
principle established in case law
we the theaters trust would be keen to
see robust evidence that the alexandra
and the cinema with the cinema operating
operator having vacated
to a new site as proposed
need evidence to to suggest that it
could not sustain additional theater
live performance and association
functions without such information
information the proposed conversion
and integration of the alexandra into a
market hall risk conflicting with the
council's own local policy plans
on the loss of local facilities as well
as failing on heritage grounds in terms
of looking first to optimum value uses
of which remove or diminish the need for
harmful alteration
so what the theaters trust are saying is
that what should have been exhausted
fully and properly before plans came
through to come up with something that
might be like the dawlish pavilions
though the drawings do not belie that
that
the
council had an obligation to consult
with all bodies we were privileged on
thursday to sit in a room of 25
organizations
all of which looked at the plans that
were on offer and were
to to a single organization
we're very clear that the the offer
within the current uh
future high streets bid is not fit for
purpose for live performance it's a form
of cultural vandalism that we will be
regretting for generations every town
of the scale of newton abbott deserves a
mid-scale arts hub most towns have them
if you look at the uh the palace in in
painting if you look at the tivoli in
wimborne
if you look at every quarter bridge
development that i've seen to date
altering them
crew
they're functioning uh in towns that
have mid-scale venues
the home of frank matcham
the birthplace of frank macham the
person the architect that gave the uk
the pavilion uh the the london palladium
uh the blackpool grand the proscenium
arch theater theater as we know it today
his his own town has its own fully
functioning historic
proscenium arch theater it would be an
act of
insanity of cultural vandalism
to rip this out before before exhausting
all avenues and the consultation has not
been full has not been proper and has
not been thorough so
before
any vote is put forward
i i would
put forward my own amendment to this
that we need to go back to first
principles on this and rather than have
a closed working group we need a a full
and proper and robust consultation that
takes on board every member that
attended the meeting
of the of the newton cic
in a full and open
way
and that then
the plans can be revisited and the
conversations can be had with the future
high streets trust because if we do not
do this the theater's trust as they
pointed out would not support the
planning application and without their
support
this council will be
recklessly uh risking the 9.2 million
pound grant themselves rather than the
fact that they're currently suggesting
that the other groups are trying to do
the very same thing so for future
generations uh i i think it's it's
within um
our absolute obligation so i would like
to put forward the amendment that was
put forward previously and and uh and
not agreed that uh if this motion is
backed then it should be backed on the
basis that we proceed without removing
the back wall of the proscenium arch
theater and the changes can be made
within that
uh
within the existing and historic
uh setting of the alexandra theater so i
proposed that motion and ask if anyone
would second that motion
counselor hawking second seconded it
thank you thank you very much um i'll
move counselor cox
because you can wait for the microphone
please
uh council really is wrong there can be
no nothing superior to the pavilions
that tinworth nothing can be better than
the infinitive and that that is the
model we should be looking for the
alexandra's
cinema actually is i know it as i was 12
years old with the gang we went to the
alexandra cinema i had no idea it was a
theater in like in the late 1970s when i
visited it when i took my children there
to watch scooby-doo ii um some 15 years
ago i had no idea it was a theater it
was a lot a lot more hygienic i have to
say than when i had visited in in as a
12 year old so i had no idea it was a
theater it was always known as a cinema
now that may be because i've
come from tinmuth and i've had loads of
correspondence about this and i have
asked people you know when did it when
did it start being called a theater
again you know before 1927 it was a
theater um and i did ask one of the uh
people did they know about the bushel
fish and they said oh yes we use it
regularly so so the the idea that there
is actually a um
no no other theater in you never it's
slightly wrong i don't know if if the
bushel is perfect or it's a thing but i
mean as um
uh council wrigley said he i watched the
royal shakespeare company uh do i think
titus andromedas um at dawlish leisure
center you know the world world
famous royal shakespeare company doing a
performance in a sports centre so you
know let's not get too precious about
this but i think what council wrigley's
motion has offered us is an option to
look at look at and if we have the good
services of newton at cic and certainly
john involved in that we would i think
come up to a sensible conclusion nothing
is written in stone i think it was
unhelpful that we had an illustration
that showed a sort of people eating in
the what was the alexandra uh
cinema um so i would support councillor
wrigley's proposal i think that's very
helpful i think it gives
community groups community arts groups
the chance to have a say in the way it
is done thank you
thank you very much councillor cox
councillor hawking
yeah thank you chairman
and it's funny in it how we uh sit here
and try and make decisions on something
that uh actually although we own the
building actually it's to do with newton
abbott
it's to do with newton albert people
residents visitors town council
the last time the town council was
involved in talking about the
regeneration if you like of the market
area not just the market hall but the
market area was a few years ago
this proposal come forward
as a time cancer i have not been
asked to make a comment on it
so therefore i don't believe that your
consultation has been fully made
quarter bridge have said all the way
along that to make the market hope
viable in their words then the alexander
has to go the alexander the wall between
the space the alexander theater stroke
cinema
is
has to go
because they need
they need
not this council quarter house needs
that space to be able to produce
the plans that quarter porter bridge are
putting forward
you can't expect to
take a theater
and then knock a wall down and put it
into one huge room and expect shows to
go on there
once when the panther mine goes on every
three they do three
um three shows a year the newton abbott
amatramatic people they put three shows
on because that's all
they're allowed to put on under the
lease that this type this council has
with scotch theater scott cinemas
um
so the the three shows that they're
allowed to put on they're on for a week
um scenery's up the they go in their
train they go in there um rehearsing
they've got the changing rooms there
once all that is gone
how do you expect
a pantomime to be put on in the middle
of a market hall when you've got
everything going on during the day
you've got um people milling around in
the so-called
cafe and bistro type in the evening how
do you expect people to sit there and
listen
and watch a pantomime
when all this is going on you can't
once that war goes down that is no
longer a theater it becomes a glorified
market hall with all the problems that a
market hall has
newton abbott's market has been going
now since 1220 as we all know
it has deteriorated over the last i
don't know 20 30 years
because of the way we shop now
you know you go in any high street and
you see empty shops everywhere around
newton now but it's actually doing very
well
one of the one of the main shopping um
people
business people um david austin he is
supporting the fact that we keep the
cinema
now he wouldn't be doing that if he
thought that the best way was to knock
knock the wall down and make it into a
big market to increase the football
because he doesn't believe that himself
it was funny that we all sat there and i
sat there at uh at that meet in the cic
meeting uh back last tuesd tuesday
everyone
as council dawes has said
said that the the space that's being put
forward
and it is the space that's being put
forward is the whole area and that is
the floor area including the alexander
cinema theater whatever you want to call
it
is not
is not of any good to performances
now we have a plan in front of us that i
believe could we could this council if
it fell behind it could have a win-win
situation
we could have a nice modern theater that
will equal if not better than team of
pavilions
we could have the market hall which
would be improved
we could have it could have um a
mesonated floor put in one
at one end to have your coffee stroke
bistro there is so much potential that
could be done
you would have your new theater
and you would still keep your
9.2 million
but to go down the road and ask us to
accept a plan
accept the payment of a plan that no one
knows anything about
all we've got is an is a drawing that
takes away a wall
and makes and makes two buildings into
one
no one knows what's going to be put
there even the portfolio holder doesn't
know what's going to be put there
how can you expect us as councillors
to accept that
and i for one will not
i'm here to support newton abbott its
residents
and what i believe in and i believe this
council if they're not very careful will
be making mistakes that they've made in
the past
they made mistakes with allowing the
allowing the market to be redeveloped in
the in the late 1970s
they made mistakes when they allowed
asda to be to move from where it was
going to be to where it is now leaving
newton albert with with a desolate area
and a big pit in the middle
and i can see them doing exactly the
same now if we are not very careful
and i for one do not want this council
to be seen to do that i want to be able
to set it sit in years to come and say i
supported that and i
welcome the fact that we now have a
thriving theatre a thriving market and a
thriving
cinema in our town
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you councillor hawking country
mcgregor
thank you chair um i'd like to thank uh
council jeffries for her um introduction
to this this item
i've got a number of concerns though
that have come out from both uh
councillor jeffrey's introduction and
also councillor wrigley's um very
long-winded speech
um
from my perspective i think there's
there's been a couple of clues dropped
in by by both maybe inadvertently
maybe maybe by by design
in that
we're being told that nothing's been
decided yet but we're being guided to
the fact that to make money here we need
professional management in to manage it
which effectively was one of the options
that was being discussed so it would
appear that there is definitely a a
drift towards that element to it
in terms of of the funding i'm very
happy to accept the funding i think
newton abbott could do with the the
expenditure i think there are elements
to
um
to newton abbot that could definitely do
with improving the cycle route would
make a
vast improvement
for people getting around the town
however i i am concerned that we do have
a
plan outlined for us which indicates the
direction of travel
now i've been told that i've been told
that nothing's been decided
uh that all of these things are going to
be sorted out in the next little while
and extensive consultation is going to
be made when you look at the time scale
that we've also been given in the report
it's a very shortened time scale so it
makes the consultation a shortened
consultation in to get it in time
i'm concerned over a conflict of
interest in that the
head of economy and jobs in terms of
being an officer is also the head of
planning
so we have a potential conflict of
interest there
and
when we're talking about delegating
decisions which is also part of this
recommendation that we've got
we've got a small conflict of interest
that's not to say that i'm questioning
the integrity of the any officers but
there is a definite conflict of interest
when you've got one person responsible
for the plans and then for passing the
plans so you know there's a there's a
risk there
in terms of the the designs that we've
we've had an outline for an indication
of
um
and even even the consultation responses
in the main
are for people who work small um
you know
performances to small audiences on a
level that's not really what we're
talking about we compare that to the
pavilions which will have a uh
a seating arrangement which which you
know is on a
slope
you know that's that's not what's going
to be uh outlined for the alexandra
theater and marketplace going forward
coming back to council hawking's point
about making a an informed choice
we do have the issue that
in ons earlier in this month we had a
report about the cultural quarter of
newton abbott deferred
i think from the perspective of um
when we look at the cultural quarter
that will include the alexandra theatre
and market hall
and we'll be asked to make a decision on
a on a a cultural element to it that we
could have had a report for at the
beginning of the month in ons and that's
been deferred and my question would be
why was that deferred when we're doing
all this work on the alexandra theatre
plan
and there is an element of cultural
quarter to it
so we've been asked to make an informed
choice
um about it what i would say is i would
make the amendment that we accept the
monies
on the basis that we do not have the
plans for the alexandra theatre as
outlined under consideration
thank you councillor mcgregor
does that in another amendment
do you have a second everybody
could he just explain what he actually
means by could he actually explain what
he actually means by that statement i
didn't quite understand what he meant
does he mean does he mean that we accept
the money but the theater war can stay
or does he mean that we accept the money
but we'll look into everything or i'm
not sure what he means sorry
could you elaborate um that we we vote
to
accept the funding
but that we don't pursue the current
plans as they lay down
we've got we've got one amendment today
that's what
i thought yes we've got i will come to
that in a moment there's other speakers
at the moment so
i'll move on now to councillor
councillor koglov
thank you chairman
i have considerable difficulty with this
but this is the way
simply the way i see things
while i support the use of the grant to
improve the town of newton abbott
obviously which incidentally i think is
much needed
i cannot agree with the proposal to
include the alexander theatre
i think that the theater
as it is
can only be an asset to the town
as i think i have mentioned before a
similar situation arose in buxton and
derbyshire where the opera house was
used as a cinema for a good number of
years
but later was retained as a theater
it is now very successful and brings
tourists and money into the town
it is thought that the alexander theatre
would be underused and in need of
subsidy
but this need not need to be the case if
properly run
the retention of the theater is what the
people of newton abbott want
and i think they have made every effort
to make their wishes known to the
council
the portfolio holder states that there
is considerable community support for
the plans are set out
i wonder how the community were asked
for their views and how many people were
actually consulted
no other performance space in newton
albert has the ability to benefit from
the excellent acoustics and an orchestra
pit
found in the alexander
this performance space is suitable for
theater music dance choirs comedy and
presentations
i understand that detailed preliminary
plans have been drawn up
for redesigning the interior showing a
large extendable start stage space
approximately
270 raked seats
a modern foyer
cafe and bar plus exhibition areas and
meeting space
so chairman as i said at the beginning
i think that newton abbott would
obviously benefit from the grant offered
and improvement to the to the town
in my opinion is much needed
but i go along with the wishes of the
people of newton abbott
i cannot bring myself to support the
proposal while the alexander theatre is
included
and so i too would have put forward an
amendment
that we that we
we go ahead but we leave the alexander
theatre out of this or else i'll have to
vote against the proposition
thank you
thank you councillor cochlear i've got a
few other councillors wishing to speak
but i'd just like to make one point
which councilor mcgregor brought up
regarding the uh
the alteration regarding the building
itself that obviously would have to go
through any planning committee so that
would be a decision made by the planning
committee not this council
now
councillor hook
thank you chad
um i'd like to thank um counselor
jeffries for the introduction she made
in the compelling case that she put
forward for um continuing on the path
that we've begun and it is is a path
we've been on for at least three years
if not more if you put it in context as
she did
so and i wanted to answer some of the
points that have been made
as i go through what i was going to say
there was a process of public
consultation in summer 2020
in terms of how many people were
consulted everybody in our district was
consulted and had the opportunity to
respond to that com consultation which
was clearly publicized at least twice in
the middle devon advertiser on our
facebook and um
on our website and residence newsletter
and and we had a good response across
the board and a good support for all
elements of the proposals
um
i'd like to thank also um
newton abbott cic encouraged by
councillor wrigley that to hold the
meeting where um the cultural groups of
newton abbott got together it was a
really good meeting for the piece i
could say i had to leave but um
and it was inspiring and there is
obviously a lot going on in newton about
inter in terms of cultural activities
but what was striking was how
how disparate it was in the sense that
each group didn't seem to know what the
other was doing and more than one group
outlined that and so it would be really
great if from that meeting something
positive
happened that there was coordination
promotion marketing
in a joint and coordinated manner an
event schedule etc none of that is
dependent on a venue and all of that
could have happened two three four five
years ago but i'm glad at last it's
started now
um just in terms of the length of the
process we've been on um
it's we're talking probably a couple of
decades at least in terms of laying the
foundation of what the people of newton
abba if we're talking about that would
like to see happen in their town one of
the key point
point starting points where we went and
asked the community was the 2008
community plan
the top request in that was that we deal
with queen street and um i think the way
it then transferred into the
neighborhood plan was something like the
wording of um
get the word re re-prioritizing traffic
in queen street
you know to keep it rather vague but the
idea was that it would make it more
pedestrian and shopper friendly at last
we have the chance to do that back then
we didn't have the chance we didn't have
the money it's never been there now we
have the money um the other top um one
of the other top
issues that the community mentioned was
having a cinema another one was
reviving the market and we we haven't
been able to do that and it has been sad
its demise and when i go out and speak
to the public which i do whenever i'm
speaking to them in the last year or so
i've always added on to my conversation
please can i ask you also about whether
you've heard about the future high
street fund if they haven't i've
explained what it meant and i've had a
dialogue and conversation
and i'd like to say there is not only
one conversation going on in town there
is more than one conversation and and i
would if it was to pick out the one
thing that people want to continue
talking to me about when i mention it
it's about the market and shopping
and retail and just the general demise
and sadly i have to say of that market
area of of our town
i don't agree with councillor hocking's
statement that that's just because of
the way people shop now it's not because
if you look at the evidence around the
country market towns the old market
towns are some of the towns that are
having the biggest revival now
of all the towns and and this is our
chance to be one of those reviving
market towns that is taking advantage of
its market status and and
reforming itself as that premier market
town in our district this is our our
chance to do it
um in terms of theaters working i
remember one comment um
from the meeting last week and that was
someone saying
the trouble with theaters and cultural
venues is they're never going to really
work economically i actually wrote it
down to make sure that i i remembered
that um so they never he and that's
someone presumably involved with it they
said never really work economically
they're always dependent on on grant um
help
um
in terms of um
the amendments um council adore's
amendment i think is
asking for con
a proper continuing whatever community
engagement with those groups that are
affected
that is what's happening so we have emma
twamley she's done some um meetings
already um if there are any groups that
feel they weren't involved in that that
would like to be involved
then
yes please give your name and you can be
involved in the continuing process of
engagement to work out the best use of
that space to satisfy as many needs as
possible
so you know just drawing together
you know this is a major investment into
the economy of our town
the main town of our district which is
what it should be it should be the main
destination
um and it should be re um rebuilding its
premier market town status and you know
some of those comments about you know
what you want the legacy your legacy to
be or what do you think future
generations are going to think of the
decision you make today
well i think they'll think we're fools
if we turn away or risk at all the loss
of 9.2 million pound investment into the
future economy of our main town so um
let's welcome this
investment and continue with the
positive discussions
we've had and hopefully we'll continue
having but within the within the funding
criteria as they are
the do nothing stay as you are option is
not an option that any of us should be
contemplating
and so i'll be supporting the
recommendations and
the additional one that nina put forward
at the beginning thank you
thank you thank you now cancerous swain
right behind you
thank you um i want to thank everyone
that's emailed me about this issue and
i've replied to all but the latest and
i've had some very interesting
conversations with people which has
helped me to try and understand both
sides of this question um
i agree with the leader of the
conservative group who said earlier
that revenue support grant had been
dropped to zero
that's a payment previously made by
conservative government and he welcomed
that and he also welcomed a donation
from a member of the public which helped
to fund council services um but
whether conservatives think the council
needs more money or less the reality is
we are living with austerity policies
and the council does not have a lot of
money and we have to be very careful
with every penny
and we need this funding for newton
abbott the suggestion that we should
reject the entire package because we
can't deliver a full-time theater
is not one that i can support
um the
amendment to retain the back wall does
in effect create full-time theatre and i
think it's important to to
realize that it's not currently a
full-time theater this would be creating
a new resource uh which would be a great
thing and i'm not against it but that's
a big ask and it's a big new facility
that doesn't currently exist so we're
not just asking the council to refrain
from knocking down the wall we're asking
them to create a full-time theater and
we've got to be careful with that and
check whether it's affordable both
immediately and in the long term and
whether it jeopardizes the funding
um
the reality of austerity policies and
also the conditions of this funding is
that resources have to be used in a very
versatile way and i think versatility is
the key
um i do understand the concerns but one
of the best theater performances i've
seen it was the tempest performed on a
beach
so
so i am concerned i am concerned about
the
about the concerns raised about the
features of the theater and
traditional theater is one of the things
that we need to try and accommodate in
that new space and i think that's really
important so i welcome the amendment to
form a steering group and i want to make
sure that those concerns are heard and
i've asked been asking questions myself
about the arrangement of seating
storage and facilities for longer term
plays i think these need to be taken
into account and i think the steering
group will do that
but i can't support an amendment to
retain the back wall because it's asking
too much
thank you
thank you council swain councillor
malone
thank you
yeah i can't really believe this stuff
i'm hearing
i've been at best in a fridge i've seen
hms pinafore up a tree it's it goes to
it it can do it anywhere it's nonsense
and this argument goes against
everything that you're trying to prove
that this can be a workable space and
all these people saying oh is it a
theater i didn't know a theater yes it
is a theater i was there three weeks ago
uh watching aladdin i've got a son who
is aspergic i've got another son who's
adhd uh i've got a little girl who's
five and has the attention span of a
caffeinated goldfish i didn't think they
would put down the nintendos but they
did and
they could talk about nothing else for
the next two days it was a wonderful
thing it was a cultural thing
it was a joyous thing it was a newton
abbott thing and it was the very essence
of the community
feeling that provides football and gives
a center and a heart to this town that
you're all vacillating about frankly it
was there it existed and just to recap
on the theater's trust they see it as a
theater and they are going to fight
tooth and nail so if you take this to
the wire and then come up against them
they have a judicial precedent and it
will be turned down so if anyone's going
to lose this money it's you
taking this to the wire without talking
to people
and it's wrong that you should
put that blame on other people saying
you're going to lose us the money
they're just fighting for what they
think is right and that is their
democratic right so can we stop trying
to and can we stop please going on about
the bushel because it's not a theater
that is in common use
it can't take travelling shows
it's in constant use by the school i've
looked into using it it's very difficult
so can we stop with this nonsense
because you're just taking people for
idiots the bushel theater is not a
theater that this town has access to
and the theater's trust will not see it
as that believe me
now
can we just
i mean nobody with any background in the
theater arts has been consulted on this
at all with respect to council jeffries
i believe her degree is in fine arts
it's not the same thing
and all the people that could have
helped that could have had some friendly
input have been just been turned down
ignored
it's ridiculous
and and what's going on what's so
disappointing about this
is that the entire process
it's just the level of misinformation
and deceit i mean
the council knows this
this scheme has no local support in
newton albert but instead of
acknowledging this instead of working
with the interesting bodies to find some
middle way we've had you know we've had
all sorts we've had a memorandum of
understanding there was no such thing
uh we've had uh we've had a constant
litany of of of of
anecdote oh i spoke to somebody in there
really behind it i spoke to people in
this town who we don't believe you
nobody believes you i've seen letters in
the local press with made-up names on
them written by counselors in this room
right made-up letters
parroting what they'd said two days
before in council to the word that you
know people aren't stupid and they're
not buying this you know councillor
dewhurst who a few weeks ago said
told everyone that the friends of the
theater were broadly behind these plans
said yesterday referred to them as an
extremist fringe group with no interest
in newton abbots
how dare an elected representative a
servant of the people
talk to people like that
this whole system has been
horrible
this whole process has been wrong
i mean this meeting last tuesday uh
counselor jackie hook turned up uh and
was then but didn't engage with any of
them 22 groups representing 22 different
forms of art and of
performance art all saying this is awful
nothing can be performed here this will
not work for anything
you know this will be in constant use
this will be in no use
it's no use to anyone
councillor hook didn't engage she walked
out of there councillor wrigley was
there
he let everyone told everyone in that
meeting that this meeting was purely to
discuss accepting the money it's not
that's that's not all this meeting is
about
and i would ask people why they are
deliberately setting out to misinform
and mislead the public
now i don't even know why part two of
this meeting
some of this meeting is in is in part
two i think the public ought to be able
to hear it because newton abbott people
should be able to hear it when all we've
heard so far is people who do not live
in newton abbot
pushing this scheme telling people who
live in newton abba sometimes
you know for generations about what it
needs to be vibrant get football that it
footfall that it needs tlc
and you know
these people don't live here you have no
idea
nobody in this town supports this they
hate it and they're starting to hate you
and all that they've had in return for i
have to say are really really polite a
really really patient attempt to engage
with you
all they've had is being maligned and
abused and called childish names
now
i i don't know how any of you can sit
here
and vote for this and say oh future
generations would look down on us if we
didn't future generations will not speak
your name yeah you won't get served in
there's still people in this town who
don't get served in pubs because of pen
in you are very much in that tradition
and no others thank you
[Applause]
councillor bradford
thank you chairman
first of all i am not against the
acquisition of the future high street
fund for newton albert
but what i am against is the needless
desecration of the alexandra theatre
and obviously i am not the only one
i have received countless emails as i am
sure that all you all have from many
residents of newton abbott
and beyond
there are over six and almost 6 000
signatures on the petition
save the alex
they are all very upset
and cannot believe that this could be
the plan
surely we have been elected by the
people for the people
why when we hardly have any culture in
newton abbot would you want to get rid
of the little that we do have
a theater is where magic happens
our theater
is unique it's a grade two listed
building
number one two five
six eight
nine three
and yes it is
listed as a theater
counsellor jewhast councillor cox
councillor swain
not a cinema
may i remind you of the course strategy
document by tdc
dated 2013-2033
the overall vision and policy objectives
for newton albert
n a 11
c
forms of development that respect the
heritage and cultural assets in this
area of the town center
i'll repeat it
forms of development
that respect the heritage and cultural
assets in this area of the town center
policy em-5 heritage assets says
development which would be likely to
directly or indirectly harm such
an asset
will not be permitted
unless there is sufficient information
available to make an informed decision
on the impact
the benefits of the development outweigh
the harm and if the benefits cannot be
provided through an alternative
less harmful location design or form of
development
i've studied all the facts and findings
and i don't believe there is sufficient
information
and there is an alternative
and i can say that with certainty
because before becoming a counsellor i
studied theater for many years at
dartington
and i worked in theaters both locally
and further afield for a further 25
years
in fact myself and my two colleagues
have a wealth of experience in the
performing arts
and only people who are practitioners
within the business know exactly how and
what goes into making a production
successful
the amount of precise collaborative work
is enormous
you have a working theatre
with a proscenium arch stage
an orchestra pit
a full license lighting rig
a recently refurbished auditorium
everything you need for any performance
the proposed scheme will simply provide
a small space for a solo artist
we offered our
expertise way back we actually asked to
attend a zoo meeting in march 2021 with
the council and photo
but we were refused by councillor
connect
being marginalized when you know you can
be of assistance is the pits
it's like building an igloo and having
eskimos on your team but not asking for
their assistance
just rude
quarterbridge have absolutely no
performing arts background
none
nil
and some unsavory dealings by them have
come to light which all counsellors have
been sent via email
surely none of you want our building our
precious building and our wonderful
market traders
to be left in the control of a company
that has disputes over their work and
ethics in other parts of the country
the hooks informed me that quarterbridge
are only consulting at the moment
well i reiterate what i've just said
they have no performance background they
shouldn't even be consulting on a
project that involves a theater
how much have they been paid
whose idea was that
we would have done it for
nothing there are alternatives the
people and businesses of newton albert
have been and still are providing us
with alternative plans
they are desperately wanting you to vote
to keep their theater
the arts are needed everywhere they're
so important especially now and
definitely in newton abbott
we have the chance to
enhance our time for the sake of our
children and grandchildren and all
future generations but without taking
away their rich legacy of a building
that is a is a working theater
it's our heart and our soul
i'm a newton abbott girl
and i care about our town
our heritage
it wasn't that long ago that one
particular council wanted to rid us of
our clock tower
we have long memories in newton abbott
and i know a lot of you don't come from
this town
but i urge you not to vote for the
destruction of our only theater
where the magic happens
thank you
[Applause]
thank you councillor bradford i know
there's a number of people who keep
raising their hands i've got you all
listed but i do intend to hear from
people who haven't had a
time to speak first if that's okay so
i've noted you got your hands up it's
going to take a little while so please
bear with us
councillor pedrick
uh thank you chairman
um firstly i feel that we need to grasp
this funding with great enthusiasm as
soon as we possibly can without doubt
now when i was a fresh-faced schoolboy
many years ago
the cultural epicenter of dawlish was a
wooden hut next to the gas works it was
quite a sizable wooden hut i mean it
served the military i think during world
war one and had been dismantled from
older shot and then moved to dawlish and
it was our cultural epicenter
i attended many functions there was a
child pantomimes children's parties
celebrations exhibitions and it was also
widely used by the local drama group as
well and coral groups
approximately 60 years ago it was deemed
that the building was no longer safe for
use because it was wooden is in conform
with certain regulations so it had to be
demolished
there was the opportunity for children's
parties and and exhibitions and
celebrations to be held elsewhere there
were other rooms available within within
dawlish but the drama society they
didn't have an option and they thought
that they would actually look for a
suitable building for themselves
and they found a building in dawlish
which was called the shastri hall
which was on the market for two and a
half thousand pounds and it was
estimated that it would cost a further
thousand pounds to convert the building
into a theater although the drama group
at the time only had 40 pounds to their
name
the committee took the brave decision to
purchase the building
the building was originally constructed
in 1881 and have been used for meetings
and a variety of social gatherings
the drama group
embarked on a vigorous fundraising
campaign and were successful and raised
the money the shasta theater was finally
opened in september 1959
the stage area measured just 19 feet by
19 feet and at the time there was a
seating capacity of 147.
initially tubal chairs were used um
wouldn't be acceptable now of course
they were tied together with string but
um fortunately then tiered seating was
was was the money was raised for tear
seating at a later date now since then
this theater has really gone from
strength to strength
um
next month there's a play being
performed by the local drama group
written by jim cartwright called two
the following month on the 16th of april
there's an abba tribute band and i think
it will pay well because returns being
charged 19 pounds each to go into it so
and in between that the the shaspy
theater is used for other things for
birthday parties if someone wants a
special birthday party and they want to
watch a movie at the same time then they
can do that
now
there is
living in a town that's got a theater
it's got something special actually um i
mean we go to the theater in plymouth
and also to uh the theater princess
theater we pay extortionate money to
park there um
but there's something quite pleasant
about going to theater in your own town
as you walk into water theater you
come across like-minded people that are
going in the same direction when you get
there there's a
group of local people waiting to get in
and it's local people that are going to
be entertained by local people which is
quite something
and it's good for the community
i mean i i would hope that somehow today
we come to a compromise or find a
compromise so that the the alex could
stay i mean i'm not totally convinced
that we need to put a lot of funding
into it though to create the uh a a
venue with uh expensive tiered seating
and so on i know it has to be conformed
with legislation
um but i i rather hope that today we can
reach a compromise please
thank you
[Music]
thank you councilor patrick and
cancer patch
thank you chair um with apologies to
councillor malone i will put on record
that i too have seen the tempest by the
rsc um although it wasn't at dawlish it
wasn't up a tree it was during lockdown
and it was streamed to a computer screen
now it seems to me
that a lot of the impetus behind um sort
of the proposed development um the
people behind it would be quite happy
seeing a very large tv screen on the
wall in a market space and that and that
would actually satisfy the cultural
aspirations um that seem to be sort of
overridden by money
interests in this
i'd just like of the main point i'd like
to make is that um this isn't just an
issue for newton as abbott residents
and for those members here who represent
newton ab awards i've received like a
lot of counsellors a great deal of
correspondence on this issue
much of which has been from residents of
my ward
this should not be seen as just a new
inhabit issue
but a wider team bridge issue there are
people out in
the rural wards
who are greatly upset by these proposals
as well and who have been asking me to
represent their views to to this council
i will be fully behind
the amendment put forward by councillor
doors i i think there must be a
compromise where we can accept the money
go forward with the transformational
project but retain
that theater space
as a as a whole theater and a functional
theater for all of the time
[Applause]
thank you cancer patch uh cancer
dewhurst
thank you chair and uh thank you uh to
councillor jeffries uh for her
presentation and to our offices um who
have spent literally years
producing
this and i just really want to come back
to the recommendations
because we have three recommendations we
have a recommendation to accept the
money
we have a recommendation to delegate
authority
to enable the project to be delivered
and we have a recommendation to form a
committee
to keep an overview of what is going on
i see that in reading the papers the
scheme will seek to deliver a flexible
space for performance live music art
craft groups and public display and to
me that sounds pretty much like a
theater
it also it it also
it so we we didn't interrupt you um so
it also uh provides
new retail space
new food space
pop-up retail areas
and of course as councillor hooks
mentioned
a new cycle route improvement to queen
street there are
there are many many benefits uh flowing
from this money uh it's also a situation
that here today
unless we accept this money this nine
million
uh
it goes back to government if we don't
use it it just goes back to
government
and in fact the alexandra cinema will
remain it will be a theater for three
weeks of the year and for the remaining
year it will remain as a cinema
so for that reason i'm going to vote to
accept the um
the the money
i'm going to vote to accept
the authority to deliver the project
and i'm going to vote
for the
the amendment to produce
the committee uh to overview this and uh
as far as i can see that will be to the
benefit of newton abbott and the whole
of the cambridge district thank you
thank you councillor
we're still going um another council who
hasn't spoken as yet is councillor
gordon hook
thank you chair
i think we ought to take a a deep breath
and a step back
there's uh
a lot of heat being generated and maybe
not quite as much light as they should
be because
we are we are faced here with with a
real dilemma
let me let me suggest for one moment
that there's nobody in this room
this morning this afternoon now um who
actually wants other than the best for
newton albert
the best for the district
the best for the arts and culture of the
area
i think in that context we're all in the
same boat we all we all want
we all want to see progress made
and in that context i i was going to use
the word that john peter just used and
absolutely he's absolutely right there's
going to have to be a compromise
across the board
and that may not be welcome in some
years but it happens to be the case now
theater is fantastic
it's great fun
i've danced here i say it i'm sorry i've
sung dare i say it on on
the stage at the the coast and hall
bristol now there's a risky thing to say
at the moment i've danced on the regal
at gloucester i i
um
i had a minor role in
um various uh things i i played opposite
esther smith in in uh the gypsies and i
had a small part in june's end i have
loved theater i have loved drama i could
go on with various examples of stages
i've performed on some in more or less
inebriated state but but you know it's
been it's been fun yes we all enjoy it
and let's do all we can to ensure that
that that fun element and educational
element who knows it might have
contributed to my political career the
experiences i've had on stage who knows
let's all take a step back and and
review what this is about because we all
want an arts
cultural
retail
hub
that generates
the economy of newton albert if you
don't
leave the room now please because you're
not fit to be on this council
however let's also state a few facts in
all this
this
vote in
ten minutes half an hour two or three
days time
is is is not a it's not a basis liquor
is all sorts you know you can't put your
hand in and have this bit but not that
bit you can't have
these bits and reject that
it's a it's fundamentally the basic
basic basic fact is do you want 9.2
million pounds for the regeneration of
newt network well don't you
because that's essentially what we have
to vote on
i want to see live theater in newton
other
i want to see a cultural hub in newton
albert
but i want to see jobs in new melbourne
i want to see an active retail thriving
retail in new norfolk
and we're talking about families here
putting meals on tables
because rejecting 9.2 million nothing
short of bonkers utterly stark staring
bonkers
take that on board
i don't say that lightly
it's it's very very important that we
get this money
mentions be made of a petition where
x number of names are on it well
let me tell you straw in the wind but my
neighbors voted for that with that
petition they signed that petition their
families did
they didn't realize that they what they
were voting for they thought they were
voting to stop the the destruction of
the theater
or the cinema whichever you want to call
it let's not be pedantic about this
they thought they that the cinema was
going to be pulled down
and that's what they signed the petition
for now it was only that's only ten or a
dozen but you know how many times can
that be multiplied
it's
incredible you know i checked out my
nose thank you um
it's incredibly important i think that
that we we accept this money because if
we don't what message does that send
it sends a message that we don't care
about newt another you vote against this
money this morning
and you're voting against the future of
newton
you're voting to maintain indifference
you're voting to retain a steady decline
you're voting against families and
employment jobs income in newton other i
can't live with that you might be able
to you vote against it and in so doing
you are you are
denigrating the future of this town
that's important to me
over to you thank you
thank you councillor hook
and councillor rolison
and can i just say at this time once the
counsellors who haven't had a chance to
speak about this at their voice i shall
be recommended that we go into part two
at that time because uh anything you
want to come back may be resolved with
financial details so i shall be
recommended at that time we go into part
two so anyone who's asked to speak again
then that's what we will be doing so in
the meantime there's two counsellors who
haven't spoken on this item and then we
will i recommend we go into part two
cancer rollers
thank you chair um i'd like to start by
saying i i think we should support this
proposal and we need to vote to take the
money and
for further consultation and engagement
with the community i'd like to thank
councillor jefferies and councillor
wrigley especially council really
through his concise informative and
precise uh delivery of his reasons
as he normally does
i think there's a danger that we're
looking
just to focus on on the theater and the
preservation of a theater and losing the
site of losing nearly 10 million pounds
9.2 million pounds worth of investment
in development
and
that development will actually include
opportunities to have the performing
arts in many varieties and shapes and
forms that they come in
it's not the loss of three weeks a year
it's actually the opportunity to have
more
uh in community events throughout the
week throughout the year and i think we
can't say that we're losing our cultural
heritage neither are we losing a grade
two listed building it will be restored
more to its former glory and it will
still be there so the say that the
theater the building has been destroyed
is not true is it it will be there there
will be opportunities for performing
arts but we can't lose sight of the
bigger picture for the economy the
employment and the vibrant future for
newton abbott and the surrounding areas
somebody referred to the children going
off to bristol and london that's exactly
where my children are going and they're
unlikely to come here till they retired
long after i have gone
they would they like the vibrance of
their communities which has all the
things that are on offer in newton abbot
if we take this uh opportunity you must
do this you're not losing the theater
you're not losing your cultural heritage
you've got to keep sight of the big
picture grab this money because it'll
never come again
and i think i understand that the
high streets are still dying all around
the country and here and we know
performing arts can perform anywhere my
brother's an actor he actually puts on
productions in theaters in yorkshire and
he works in the community from pubs to
sports halls to anywhere that have him
he's actually performed at tottenham
castle and it's been referred to that
royal shakespeare company can perform in
a sports hall of course
real actors dedicated people can perform
anywhere it's their art their love you
don't need to sit in a box and take
what's given to you performing arts are
far more interactive now and that's what
engages the younger people especially
and i thoroughly enjoy that kind of life
so i urge you really just to vote for
this we're not losing anything we're
going to gain an awful lot
so thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much coach jordan and
council russell
hand up
oh thank you chairman i i just wanted to
um
just let members know about our
experience at tinmouth
when we had the choice of losing the old
much-loved carlton theatre
and to
go for a big
opportunity to
provide a multi-use
an office space and get some money from
the government to do that
and that's how the pavilions came about
uh there was a lot of uh sorrow to lose
the carlton theater but it was riddled
with asbestos and it was uh quite
unsuitable for modern day audiences so
we we didn't have any choice
but at the same time we still have the
riviera cinema which is still there if
the auditorium is still there although
it's a church it is used in the
old-fashioned way as a cinema but it
doesn't have the facilities by any means
and we all sit there on the old horse
air seats and and put up with it but
it's a nostalgic evening rather than
anything else but the pavilions does
serve as a very good uh service in
it provides widescreen theater
ride screen cinema and theater
performances and
we have the folding seats but we only
have 220 seats in the pavilions against
the 450 seats we had at the carlton
theater so we have had to make some
changes but i can understand why newton
albert wants to keep the alexander
theatre i've been to performances there
the seats are extremely comfortable and
it's a lovely experience so if there was
some middle way
are we saying that the alexandra theater
is something wrong with it structurally
as was the case with the carton theater
where we had the asbestos problem and we
had to it had to go
is this is there a structural problem
why the alexandra theater cannot be
still utilized within the new
development because it's it it is
it is a heritage building and it's much
loved by the local community so has
enough thought being given to trying to
keep it as it is within the new complex
as a heritage
as a heritage building that people would
love to see
you know glass and concrete is all very
well but it's not the same as the old
buildings and the solid buildings that
are that are that are bound in newton
but look at the library for instance uh
to get an experience to
to experience real theater real theatre
seats instead of ones that fold back and
it's a multi-use it's very good the
multi-use it's good at the pavilions i
have to say but it's it's not quite the
theater
as you have in alexander thank you
[Applause]
thank you councillor russell and i think
that's
one of the points where a part two
discussion is needed because some of
these things cannot be answered unless
we go into to part two i've one one more
counselor then we will decide to go into
part two if so wished councillor hayes
to the right
uh thank you chair i'll make this quite
brief
yes i've had questions and skepticals
specifically about the development
of the alex picture acts as i know it
and how that will move forward and i do
welcome the fact that there will be
ongoing engagements especially with all
the stakeholders held
and of course this new steering group
which should help as well
so i'm actually in a dilemma here
i do come from a smaller part of
stage background
doing sound and backstage stuff in my
youth
so i do appreciate what
theaters are like
and the dilemma is my heart is telling
me that i'd love to see this building
as a theater but my head is telling me
9.2 million pound you cannot refuse
this kind of investment in this town you
can see where newton abbott's going we
have newton's place now we have the
cover over market walk and this extra
9.2 million might just be
the bit that pushes newton abbott
forward and continues its major senior
town
not only in team bridge but probably in
devon
so i welcome this and just a footnote
you know what the young people call
newton abbas they call it newton um
scabit
and also
downton abbott as the fact that they're
still in the dinosaur area so this is an
opportunity just to move us forward i
think
i do feel sorry for people who who come
from a stage background yet
i understand that i get that it's
emotional the grease paint the roar of
the crowd and all that it's good
but unfortunately 9.2 million i'm afraid
takes priority
thank you
thank you council hayes i i realize
councilors got their hands up about
coming back but this debate is not
finished and whatever points you want to
come back on we'll come back on in part
two
and we we can come back on them
councillor hawking in part two
i i will allow i will allow your points
you are you want to make a point
councillor hawking you were on the list
to come back i know
you'd like thank you chairman
a couple of points i want to make number
one is once the wall is taken down the
theater is no longer a theater the space
will be a big open
open
shed type space it will just be a market
ting of pavilion has a theater it may
not be
what they had before but they still have
a purpose a purpose-built
theater unit within the pavilions
you take away that wall newton albert
will lose that they will not have that
we keep on about this 9.2 million
let's be very very frank here what this
9.2 million is being spent on
a lot of the money is being spent on a
tinbridge asset
a grade two asset that tinbridge has the
right and
uh legal obligation to keep in a right
in order
that's what we're being asked to be
announced to vote on
it will not
in my view
make any difference
to the high streets of newton abbott
newton abbott high street is probably
bearing better than anywhere else in the
country with the number of shops that we
got empty there is more shops
empty within tingbridge's own market
walk than there is
in the in our high street
so
it is a tingbridge asset tingbridge are
asking us to make sure that we vote for
money to enable them
to upgrade their asset
and that's what we got to remember it is
nothing to do with um improving our high
street yes sir spend a little bit on
upgrading queen street which people
didn't want anyway
um
what they originally wanted for queen
street was it to be fully fully
pedestrianized at the top end and that
never came about because devon county
council turned us down because they said
they had no money this is a what you're
going to do to queen street is a halfway
house
and i really do urge everybody within
this room to stop and think when we
start going into part two and i really
don't see why we should be going into
part two anyway but to stop and think
what you're actually saying you're
spending this money on you're spending
on a team bridge asset
thank you
right no i'm going to recommend
no
that
i'm sorry i'm going to insist at this
time we're going to go into part two we
are going to
okay we can continue to debate in part
one
but confidential information can only be
disclosed in part two
so if there's anyone else who wants
a small amount to be brought at this
time we will accept that but then i'm
going to go i'm not going to come back
again and again to people because we
will come back into part one after part
two so that will be in the public domain
it's not a question of hiding it in any
way so i'm the person who's come up
before anybody's cancer doors i will
allow that but i'm not going to go any
further i'm going to recommend part two
at that time sorry no one else
all the votes will be taken part in part
one we will come back into part one and
everything that has been discussed and
voted on will be in part one with the
public present
okay so i will allow cancer doors but
that is it at this time
thank you yeah i just wanted to speak as
i put forward the amendment and there's
been a very uh
a lot of points put forward a lot of
them uh very interesting and i'd like to
come back on those uh councillor jackie
hook pointed out that uh when she came
to the cic meeting there were 25 groups
there and not a lot of those groups knew
what was going on and there was no
joined up thinking
and that's correct that that was a quite
a shocking position for us all to be in
uh every city i've operated in before in
when i was in brian hove uh well with my
venue in bath as well they've had
cultural groups that have been run by
the councils that have
had cross
between the groups so i'd probably
invite the arts and cultural member
champion uh from the lib dem executive
to tell us what they have been doing and
why that disconnect exists at that point
in time i wasn't aware there was an arts
and culture member champion uh until the
theater's trust wrote to them last
thursday
and i suppose all the counselors in this
group this room probably know who that
person is or maybe they don't uh the the
the other thing that uh i'm a bit
worried about is the sort of uh
selective quoting because uh again
councillor hook came to that meeting and
and left at half time with the uh with
the words uh it will never work
economically uh there's a lot of context
to that because the arts are a balance
uh they're like education uh they uh
some of them work financially uh uh in
in different settings uh the larger the
group
the larger the scale it needs to be to
stand up economically that doesn't mean
that you can't tour something on a small
scale because many groups around the
country have funding to do very much
that just to un and financially viable
shows to towns and cities across the
country so if you have an orchestra or
in fact you have pantomime groups people
will give their time for nothing so so
the the there is a balance there and
there are examples of best practice in
many cities and towns of the same size
of new nubber where
mid-scale theatre and theatre hubs work
perfectly well and
the other thing that people seem to
conflate and and confuse and are using
it to to some odd ends
is that what's the cinema and what's the
theater well i'm sorry everybody cinemas
are these they call cinema theaters um
the the greater listing that exists
isn't the outside of the building that's
another misnomer the listing is a
greater listing on the alexandria
theater as it stands and it would take a
historic england and the theatre's trust
to allow any degradation of that
i'll give you some light uh where none
can be shown
because uh i have
renovated a cinema a derelict cinema
and taken it from an empty shell that
was left empty by the abc in in bat uh
invested a million pound of mine and my
share uh co-owners uh business owners
money into regenerating a business that
took 10 years to stand on its feet
financially all at our own risk
ultimately we put it into a
community benefit society so that it
works on cooperative ground a
co-operative model it's actually the
perfect example of how a mid-scale arts
hub can work for all communities between
our two venues we have 250 000 customers
a year
and when people are pontificating in
here about what the young people want i
know exactly what they want because they
come into my venues i also know what the
middle age people want and i know what
their 93 year olds want because we
entertain them across
all genres
across all age groups
and
the idea that you can perform anything
anywhere is correct yes you just have to
build a theater around them you have to
provide the lighting you have to provide
the sound you have to provide the
backdrop what works is when you have a
mid-scale theater and the answer where
people can turn up and they don't have
to build the theater around them so
the theater's trust letter that has not
been referred to that was sent to our
cultural
uh member champion uh who who has failed
to share it to other members is sat in
everybody's inbox i will distribute it
uh because i've printed copies as well
and uh and the the within that they they
also reference the misnomer that having
a school theater somewhere outside of
the town center is in some way a
replacement and going back to the very
last thing that they say if the current
plans are progressed without compelling
evidence and justification for the loss
of theater performance provision we will
be strongly objecting to the relevant
planning application
as you note
the 9 million pounds might be lost it
will
if you do this brinksmanship and decide
to destroy the alexandra theater with
this vote today which is what you're
going to do
this council will bear the
responsibility for risking recklessly
the 9.2 million pounds that could be
invested into an arts and cultural club
that would sit alongside a very well
funded and
well functioning
uh
market hall in a vibrant town that we
can all be proud of thank you
okay i'm going to move a recommendation
for part two shortly but before i do
just one matter we have this council has
decided to accept the money from the
high street fund last year it is just
the budget that we're on for that
project that we're talking about here
today so at this time i would like to
recommend that under section
a
bracket four of the local government act
1972 that the press and public be
excluded from the meeting during
consideration of the following item on
the grounds that it involves likely
disclosure of exempt financial imp
exempt information as defined in
paragraph three financial matters of
part one of the schedule 12a of the act
i would like to propose that can i have
a secondary secretary council mcgregor
thank you can i have a show of hands
that we all agree with that
against
abstentions
that's carried we might move into part
two can i confirm that we're going to
start live streaming but there is a
slight delay so we will confirm when
we're actually uh
being live streamed
probably a minute or so
we're okay apparently
we are live streaming okay we we've come
out of part two so um there was an
amendment which was put forward by
councillor klokov and that was seconded
i think by cancer clarence that's right
yes so um in the amendment can you tell
me uh confirm exactly kanchok what the
amendment was so we can all know what
we're voting for or not
that we
uh welcome the nine million uh to
renovate
a much needed
job in newton abbott to bring it up to
scratch but that we leave the alexander
theatre out of the proposal and just
keep it as a building which is an asset
to the town as it is
okay that's a straightforward proposal
and you're happy with that cancer
clarence right
uh can we go to the vote on that
amendment please
point of order
and what breach are we talking about
uh we'd like to make this a recorded
vote if
five people
and we would like to propose a second
amendment uh should this fail
we will deal with this one first and
then we'll see that okay
have we got five people who are going
for that standing for that
yeah looks like we've got the five yeah
okay
counterpatch
yeah well that's as i said with this is
an amendment we'll vote on that
amendment and then we'll come to that if
that's the case okay so we you've asked
for a recorded vote are we ready to do
that
councilor goodman bradbury
that's the haze
that's the hocking
that's the gordon hook
against the jackie hurt
councillor jeffrey
that's the jeffries
council keeling
council mcgregor
foreign
[Music]
what's up john pedreck
councillor linda pedreck
councillor pitts
councillor rollerson
yeah russell
that's the swain
that's taylor
that's a thorn
[Music]
against just checking the numbers
sorry for the delay
chair
the um the amendment is lost
uh 13 20 and
okay so that amendment is lost and i
believe that there's a possibility of
another amendment councillor patch
can you wait for the microphone please
i'm not not sure where the council of
doors amendment stood as seconded um in
which case i'd i'd put this forward as
an amendment to that amendment otherwise
i'd put this forward as a standalone
amendment
i think you need to
cancel the doors withdrew his amendment
i believe yes so
it's a new amendment
so i'm going to put forward a new
amendment uh
that hopefully someone will be able to
second so that uh the amendment is that
a steering group
of the 25
attendees or uh so who are at the cic
meeting
uh work up a fully functioning and fully
functioning and thorough business plan
to support the jeremy nukem plans for
the alexandra theater
and for those to form the first look to
optimum viable usage that remove or
diminish the need for harmful alteration
and for those to be then implemented
into the bid for the future high street
funds nine million pounds
i'm
not quite sure we've got all of that but
i'll ask
just bear with me
um
the the issue with that is that they
would have to be invited the third party
to to take part in that they can't
actually you know put themselves forward
for that something the council would
have to invite them to do
so um
that's a bit of a difficulty with that
venture patch can i propose an
alternative wording then please chair
that um the people who have put forward
the alternative is it jeremy nukem plan
um be invited to put together working
with other suitable bodies a viable
business plan as to how that might work
so that an alternative scheme to that
being presented could be presented to
members
alongside
the current proposals so that members
get to choose
which
scheme they prefer going forward would
that be acceptable
i think there's an issue with that
regarding the time scale i think
probably that's not going to
work within time
with 2024 as a as a backstop
there would still be time to work up
proposals based upon
an architect's drawn scheme that is
already put together so we're not
starting from scratch okay so you've put
that forward that's been seconded has it
by seconded
yeah by township doors we'll put that to
the vote then so
oh we yes sorry cancer hook i don't know
which one
jackie hook
thank you i was just going to um say
that if the amendment is put forward
shouldn't you allow a debate on that
amendment because um i think maybe the
officers would like to comment maybe
some of us would like to comment on the
content of that amendment
that's that's quite right um if there
are any
counsellors who would like to make uh
comments on that council royalist put
his hand up
thank you chair i i fear for the time
scale that a working group would need
to come up with a plan
i think we ought to be sure that
listening to the officers earlier that
this incorporates the entire uh bid for
the town centre and the marketplace
because that's what the money's for not
just the theater
so
can that be done and i understand that
first plan took 25 000 pounds some of
that was a government grant and about 18
months so
this this is just a stalling operation
surely
councillor jeffries there has said that
we will have a consultation and
engagement process about further
development and exactly what this
new space will look like so actually
there's plenty of opportunity to
influence the space but i really think
to go back to the drawing board is
absolutely not an option at this stage
and they've had 10 years to do this the
theater's been going for what nearly 100
years and it's not developed for
anywhere since that despite all the
consultations for development and
opportunity so i don't think they're
going to
need do this in the 10 days or 100 days
thank you i know some council's got
their hands up but can i come to neil
blaney for a bit of clarification please
uh thank you chair in terms of the the
end date of march 2024 that's to spend
the money so the project is um designed
up planning permission implemented and
then money drawn down so that that's
where that date comes from so the the
program that we've got set out is
including obviously the work that's gone
before uh and the plans are well
developed right now and just for
clarification it's 125 000 that the uh
the council was given as part of the
successful bid initially to build up the
business case um so you'd need something
similar to do the similar level of work
to make sure that
the government's a treasury that
the department for level and up
are satisfied with any alternative plans
so that time scale if it was 12 to 18
months it takes us right towards the end
of the
time period to draw down the money
without having a plan ready to go
cancer gordon hook
thanks chair
i think that councillor olison was
actually touching on where i wanted to
go and i'm seeking clarification which
is almost there but
what is there to separate
this amendment or at least the essence
of this amendment i.e that there's a
consultative group that puts together
looks at the what let's let's call it
the gerrymandering
plan and it's it's a very interesting
plan what where's the divergence between
what is proposed in
the original amendment
which very much needs
depth and substance put to the
proposal for that let's call it the open
space um and and jeremy newcomb's plan
as far as i can see is is admirable and
well it has much to um recommend it uh i
don't see that they're a million miles
apart and and i would want to see very
much um that plan
considered seriously uh
in in in the next
two or three weeks not the next three or
four months because time is a crucial
element here and i i just like
clarification as to where there is a
difference between what is proposed in
this amendment and what is possible
within the existing proposal to be voted
on ultimately
i don't know if new planning wants to
comment on that whether there is a
difference
well um
my take on the difference is uh whether
the theater is retained in attendance as
a standalone um the the both proposals
are for groups to be formed
steering groups to be chaired by council
of jefferies to engage
all the local groups uh in the design of
the space moving forward
i mean obviously if members accept
council jeffrey's proposal it would be
taking forward
the design work on the basis of
the ambitions set out in the in the
report within the budget approved and
clearly if proposals come forward that
aren't in line with the budget approved
and don't meet the criteria as set out
in the future high street fund then it's
not something that could be taken
forward so um and so depends if members
approve the recommendation today the
next step would be for officers to work
with the consultants with councillor
jeffries uh working on the creation of
the steering group
and taking forward all these discussions
to look at the final design in line with
our ambitions and in line with the
budget
okay thank you very much hawking
yeah thank you chair i don't believe i'm
hearing all this
there is a complete difference between
what council jefferies is proposing what
council jeffries is proposing is that
the market hall beca the market hall and
the alexander theater becomes one
building
what
what the book yes it does become one
building it's set out in the in the
report from quarter bridge that the only
way they can make the market work is by
increasing the the
floor space and the only way they can
increase the floor space is by taking
the center of the alexander theatre
struck cinema out and bringing it down
to the same level right the way through
that building and that building will
become one
that's what it says and that's what
they're proposing to do and all the
pictures all the diagrams that we've got
in the reports show that what we're
trying to do in this with this amendment
we're trying to
we're trying to keep the alexander as a
theater
we're trying to
get the cinema built
and we're trying to keep the market
whole on a similar size as what it is
but with a mesonated floor or something
it can be done
now come on let's stop beating about the
bush saying all it's the same it's not
it is not the same read the reports read
what it says
thank you
councillor dawes
thank you so um a couple of points the
um
the the idea that it will take a year
125 000 pounds to build a business plan
is uh probably come somewhere from
operating in the public sector what a
wonderful place to be and i wish my
business has been in that uh you can you
can create a business plan if you have
the need and motivation i think what the
amendment is trying to do
is suggest that that can then be put
forward with the plans which are trans
transformational they are a huge
departure from what is there at the
moment
uh and and then members can vote on that
please put a time limit on it that
that's absolutely fine the uh
the other suggestion that no one's done
anything with the alexander theater
wherever all these theater groups been
doing what they've been doing in the
last 20 30 40 years uh i don't know if
you notice there's a cinema operator in
there that has a lease on the building
so they haven't had any ability to do
anything the the final point i was going
to put forward as well is the suggestion
by uh councillor cox and i think neil
blaney that it's not time for the
theater's trust to be involved in this i
wonder why they put the line in their
letter that you didn't uh distribute to
members saying we urge the council to
engage with the theatre's trust as soon
as possible they're a statutory body who
want to communicate with you before
you've gone too far down the track in
destroying a heritage asset when that
need not have happened
um
sorry i've lost my
could you do someone else first place
sorry
cancer cox
i think we're we're going to
take one one or two more councillors and
then we're going to go to the vote on
that amendment nothing nothing nothing
is set in stone
the illustrations in the report are very
unhelpful frankly because they do show
uh things that
well i don't necessarily want i actually
like jeremy newcomb's idea i think we
need to be developed but that is covered
by councillor jeffrey's amendment
and that and it won't it won't be an if
or being it will become the substantive
proposal to the to the town council and
i hope that council doors is involved in
that um uh steering group in fact we
ought to invite him because he does have
a lot of expertise on that so we don't
really need uh and yeah i do agree you
can you can set up a business plan
actually for a lot less 120 000 pounds i
wish i'd have that sort of money to
spend um on business plans um so you
know
but it's unnecessary we can work with
what council jefferies has done there is
the compromise there is the there is the
argument to put forward to have a
pavilions type
uh
uh
activity center in in what is the
alexandra cinema uh so actually i i
don't think this amendment
is a semantics it does the same thing as
councillor jeffries is proposing
and it does it does it does and quarter
with quarter bridge we don't have to
they're consultants they consult we
don't have to listen to them we don't
have to accept them and i mean i don't
know if they're if they're about to be
uh prosecuted by the serious crime
office then obviously we'll find
somebody else
please i'm sorry but anyone who's
already spoken on that amendment that
they've spoken on that amendment there's
so there's no further discussion from
that individual so
please
i think
we're going to go to the vote i think at
this time we're going to the vote you
put forward a
thing councillor patch and it was
seconded by councillor dawes i'm going
to go to the vote now so
as the pro as the question for the order
yes carry on
you will be brief
i just want to say i do reckon i do
recognize the constraints of the time
scale as as more details have been given
to us so i i would be happy to
incorporate in the amendment um
subject to the agreement of my
co-sponsor of the amendment maybe
setting a time limit of say six months
for those up for those alternative plans
based on the jeremy newcomb um plan to
scheme to come forward for consideration
by members
that i would i would would think would
be achievable and that that ought not to
severely compromise the timetable
are you happy with that cancer doors
okay we're going to go to the vote on
that please
i thought
we need five yeah okay i think we've got
five
yep okay
okay can we go to a vote on that
i possibly would wasn't going to come to
that
are you going to restate it
can you restate it please
thank you then so that um a six-month
time scale be given for alternative um
scheme to be developed based on the
jeremy newcomb plans um to incorporate a
a
financially viable business plan as to
how that scheme might operate as an
alternative to what is being put forward
now and for that alternative scheme to
be comfort to come forward for
consideration by the council
is that right with you counselor doors
okay
we've asked for a recorded vote we've
had the five members standing so can we
go to
the accorded vote please
david cox
[Music]
can we repeat that please
[Music]
councillor dewhurst
that's the foden
council goodman bradbury
councillor hayes
councillor hawking
councillor gordon hook
councillor jackie hook
councillor jeffrey
councillor jeffreys
councillor keeling
councillor mcgregor
council of
councillor malone
councillor
nutley councillor patch
that's the pierce
that's the john petherick
counselor linda pedreck
chester
phipps a rollerson
that's a russell
that's a swain
that's a taylor
that's a thorn
that's a wiggly
against
chad
was lost uh
13 19 and 12th centuries
thank you sarah now we go back to i
believe the substantive and main motion
got just councillor
jeffries would you like to to restate
that
okay that we approved the budget
outlined in part two of the report to
deliver the project detailed in section
four
to delegate authority to head of place
and commercial services in consultation
with the chief finance officer and the
portfolio holder for economy and jobs
to take such decisions as necessary to
deliver the project
three that the council continues to
engage and consult with regard to the
project design
and considers the interconnected needs
of the market and cultural hub
performance space through a new steering
group chaired by the portfolio holder
for economy and jobs and that the
council's appropriate committees are
regularly updated on progress
and you can say jeffreys can i have a
second here for that please
cancel wrigley unless you did second it
sorry
i think you made a compliment comment
counselor mcgregor
just can i come back on a few points
that were made earlier on in the part
one earlier
um in terms of in terms of newton abbott
we're seeing newton abbot as a growing
town there is
significant numbers of houses being
allocated by the government to be built
within the district
a lot of those houses are going
currently the trend is to people who are
moving here from
the
south east and midlands who are moving
down here from from areas that are
theater rich
in terms of in terms of one of the
points that
councillor jefferies mentioned and it's
a really valid point
a lot of people are struggling and
they're going to continue to struggle
and they're going to struggle more going
forward
but that doesn't mean we should deprive
them of cultural capital
cultural capital is one of the key
elements of a society and its
development particularly for children
and for those who are
at the lower end of of the financial uh
financial levels
so depriving people of cultural capitals
depriving them of a proper theatre
environment
is actually contrary to
good social behavior it's not pro-social
behavior to focus on the money and the
best way to get income coming in for a
market
that we deprive people of cultural
capital so from my perspective i wanted
to make that point earlier and i've had
to wait
if the trend continues that more people
come here from out and about where are
they going to go for their evenings out
they're going to go to places that have
proper theaters that are like the ones
in london now like the ones in reading
like the ones in oxford like the ones in
birmingham these are the places where
people go and they'll go to those places
and they'll spend their money there in
the evening and
newton albert will still not have that
what newton lambert will have is a few
djs playing a bit of music in the
evening or maybe a flash mob choir
potentially although we have seen those
deteriorate because of kovid you know in
terms of
contribution to to that kind of
environment so i'm still concerned
that when it comes down to it what we're
doing is we're prioritizing the income
potentially for the market over the
cultural capital for our residents and
that's a really important thing that
hasn't been considered anywhere in this
this context
and that is a really important thing and
one last point that when councillor
jackie hook was going uh over the the
grade two listing criteria i'd just like
to re-emphasize
that the alexandra theater has unique
features for teambridge and most of
devon
it has a proscenium arch
that is is uh related to an individual
who is famous for putting those in in
theaters in london and in the midlands
and again it's those kind of things that
we would lose
we lose a real cultural gem
an opportunity a cultural gem that
brings cultural capital to those who can
least afford it
thank you
[Applause]
thank you councilman can we go straight
to the vote then please um
cancer jefferies has proposed and canson
wrigley has seconded
if you propose a co recorded vote that
is up to you
i think we've got just just the five
okay
austin
that's the bradford
that's the clarence
that's a cold cloud
councillor connect
councillor kirk
paul
councillor david cox
council hugh [ __ ]
counsellor doors
that's a due hest
that's her foden
that's a good one bradbury
councillor hayes
counselor hocking
counselor gordon hook
councillor jackie burke
councillor jeffrey
dr jefferies
counselor keeling
that's in mcgregor
cancer malone
that's so natalie
that's the patch
that's
[Music]
that's the wiggly
thank you very much so that that motion
is carried thank you very much cancers
for your consideration and that i know
it's a very very difficult situation
i think
it was handled quite well by all of you
thank you very much
can we now move on to the agenda please
i know one's apologized to me in advance
because of not being well so um
thank you very much we'll move on now to
item 11
recommendation from the executive
council dax reduction scheme that is
councillor keeling the member for
corporate services
thank you counselor keeling
thank you mr chairman
colleagues we have been successfully
running a local council tax reduction
scheme for team bridge residents
maintaining support at 100
for our lowest income households
by the scheme in 2020
introducing an income banded discount
scheme which is easier for our customers
to understand and quicker for our
council tax team to administer
and better able to cope with minor
fluctuations in universal credit
entitlement
kovid hit just as the new scheme went
live and we are very quickly saw a
massive increase in caseloads reflecting
the surge in universal credit
applications across the country
with the simplified scheme in place we
were able to respond quickly to this
increase reducing the bills on an extra
1000 claimants within the first couple
of months of the scheme going live
this increase in uptake increased costs
considerably but i'm pleased to say that
the upward trend has now reversed and
the caseload has started to reduce
although whether that will return to
pre-covered levels remains to be seen
it has been possible to it has not been
possible to access
with any certainty the impact of the new
scheme given the upheaval over the last
two years and the various temporary
government initiatives introduced to
help residents cope with the financial
impacts of kovid
it is clear to me though that despite
the increase in schemes costs this is
not the time to consider cutting support
or making other changes to the scheme
our residents need some stability and
certainty as they emerge from covid
crisis
and we need the time and a more stable
baseline to carry out a review of our
schemes performance before determining
whether we need to take
need to make any more changes for the
future in the meanwhile we can take
confidence both from the relatively
small number of exceptional hardship
applications and the
minimal number of complaints received to
date that are over overall our scheme is
meeting its objectives and further
changes can be considered if required
once more detail analysis has been
conducted
i am therefore recommending we retain
the current scheme for
2022-23
and make use of the existing provisions
to increase the income threshold to
absorb the annual increase in state
benefits
mr chairman i therefore propose to
recommend to this council that one the
existing provision within the scheme are
used to increase the upper income
threshold in band 1
from 75 pounds to 78 pounds and the
lower threshold in band b from 75 pounds
and a penny to 78 pounds and a penny
two the council tax reduction scheme
attached to appendix a is adopted for
the year 2022-23
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much secondly by cancer
connot
council mcgregor
thank you council keeling for the
the report and the introduction on that
just a quick question um admirable um
efforts like these to to help people in
real need um are always welcome
however counselor jeffries mentioned
earlier in her introduction for hers
that the expectation is that more people
this year will be in
dire need and perhaps perhaps in
suffering extraordinary hardship as a
result of both inflation rises energy
rises
and the cost of food
and making the choice between feeding
and heating
do we expect as a council that
the number of cases that are applied for
will increase and approximately by how
much
thank you council mcgregor i think i
covered that that we are ready to step
up and look after those most vulnerable
in our communities that goes without
saying
thank you thank you
cancer cox
thank you very much indeed i welcome
this and it's fantastic that we are the
only council in devon to do that and i
do contrast councillor mcgregor's
earlier comments with his recent
comments you know we're encouraging
people from the southeast to come down
here for the arts oh gosh you know i
look at i in my ward i have the the
meadow center it looks i was painting it
the other day and i looked down up up on
the the morrisons which we had 10
million this council 10 million pounds
for
we'd just like a fraction of that to
rebuild the meadow center you know
before we build theaters anyway i really
welcome i'm chairman of a food bank uh
chairman of trustees of a food bank and
we re this really is important to people
the citizens advice say that council tax
debt is the biggest problem they're now
facing once we've dealt with them payday
loans and uh 1.3 million people in the
in this country are
run out of money and are unable to pay
their council tax and with more
squeezing on people with with fuel
increases with housing costs because
people coming down from the south east
for the arts
and um
we really do need this so i do welcome
this and i know it's a difficult choice
for the council because it's money that
you know we could we could spend
elsewhere but it really is important for
the poorest and it really is the
cornerstone of this council's
anti-poverty campaign
i'll come back to you in a moment
councillor mcgregor only councillor hook
is indicating a wish to speak
thanks to just a very small point
because councillor cox alluded to it um
could somebody at the top table possibly
the managing director confirm in fact
that
84
of new residents in
team bridge have an ex former postcode
i'm not sure the figure but it's a very
high percentage and i don't know what
percentage councilor mcgregor uh was
referring to when he said
whatever word it was he used lots coming
down to to us from the south east but
figures are available to clarify whether
or not that is the case and i don't want
rumors to get legs before they've
got legs
recently when we were looking at the
housing need figures but um we'll put it
in the members newsletter for you but it
certainly was um the migration that
we're finding and not from people coming
from outside ex
thanks i just wanted to establish that
you know what is the case rather than
these things get get taken as
fact before we
very long thank you mcgregor
thank you chair i just want to correct
um councillor cox first of all and i'm
not encouraging people to come down from
the southeast just for the arts i'm
saying there's a trend at the moment
where more people are coming from the
southeast and the midlands into devon
and it's partly to do with the covid
crisis
and the need for you know and being able
to work from home with all the great
efforts that have gone in in increasing
connectivity particularly across uh the
southeast uh southwest
so that's that's not correct and equally
um when we talk about postcodes and
people moving from postcode to postcode
we remember a lot of people sell up in
london and move here and rent and have a
an ex and a tq postcode before they move
to the next address so let's not fool
ourselves about hidden numbers and and
you know trying to get legs on on rumors
it was just a comment about a trend of
people moving here
it's a fact speak to estate agents they
will tell you where people originate
from and this is something that is
happening and people are highlighting it
on facebook on other social media it
does happen it's not something that we
should be embarrassed about because it's
a beautiful area and people like to live
here people come on holiday retire here
people come down here on on holiday and
move here with their families it's not a
bad thing
but what we do what we have got to
remember is
that all of these impact
but let's not let's not pretend and
let's not politicize a comment that i
made earlier as though it's some sort of
great
indicator of my views when it was just
about trends so uh i'd thank the two
councilors concerned to
keep it on
the subject thank you thank you
councilman councillor pedrick
thank you chairman yes um firstly uh i
mean i understand that the scheme was
introduced a number of years ago
and a number of local authorities have
fallen by the wayside and they're not
deciding not to continue with it so it's
absolutely sort of heartwarming to know
that we are continuing with it um
secondly the the second paragraph of the
recommendation refers to an appendix an
attached appendix now there might be
finger trouble on my part but i couldn't
find that so i've got a couple of
questions if i may please and two
questions first question is is um how
many residents did the scheme uh help
last year and approximately how much is
it likely to cost next year thank you
thank you councillor keating
i i thank councilor patrick for that
those two questions if i can take the
second one first
we obviously don't know how much it's
going to cost because we don't know how
many applicants they're going to be
but a
number of people helped if that will um
uh i can give that information um as of
the first of february
we
team richard helped 5740
of our residents
which were receiving help with their
council tax payments
via the council tax reduction scheme and
in addition to the main scheme we have
made 31 awards of exceptional hardship
as of the 17th of january uh this year
thank you
thank you very much council keeling
right no other indicators to speak can
uh go to the vote as
councillor keeling seconded by
councillor connect all those in favor
thank you
right we'll move on now to item 12 which
is a recommendation from executive
regarding the dog pspo review and the
executive member for household waste and
environmental health cancer jewish
thank you very much chair so uh this is
a recommendation that comes from the
executive of the 8th of february this
year
and the recommendation to council is to
approve the continuation of the very
successful public spaces protection
order for responsible dog ownership
under sections 59-75
of the anti-social crime and policing
act 2014
taking into account the following
recommendations of the task and finish
group that the lead length should be
reduced to one meter and it should be a
fixed type
and that officers increase the signage
in key locations to inform the public
of the controls
and that's it
thank you very much to have a second
hour
cancer fold okay
uh council russell
just hang on a minute tim
was brought in when i was the executive
member responsible
um you don't mention the number of dogs
at any one time being controlled by a
person in there
and
you talk about the signage
toxicara is quite serious uh for
children particularly the eyesight and
there are
signs up at nhs premises and i did pass
a copy of that into david eaton to see
whether that could be placed that
signage could be placed in in areas
where where is very popular with dog
walkers
toxicara
it affects children's eyesight if they
if they happen to touch the grass so
we do have a responsibility to ensure
the safety of everybody particularly
children who
on the den particularly in the summer
they are i see all the dog walkers in
the morning early in the morning and
then the children are there
with their parents crawling around on
the same on the same grass so um if we
could look at
those sorts of protections
i'd be grateful i've spoken to david
about it before and i did show him the
poster that they got up at the nhs so
maybe that could be considered thank you
chairman thank you councillor do you
want to come back down to the dewhurst
thank you uh thank you very much chair
yes i think uh councillor russell uh for
her suggestion i think it's a very good
idea in terms of of the signage um i
think there are a number of messages we
need to get out there
and clearly that's one of them
as far as the numbers of dogs uh being
handled at any one time that's already
part of the pspo uh and
and that won't change
so this is just about the the
continuation plus the two amendments
thank you very much um councillor phipps
yeah thank you chair um just a small
query um it says here about one meter
late actually i think i was on the
committee and it was my idea to do that
but um what about somebody who's got an
extendable dog lead how do they stand
under this if we pass this that they've
got to have a one-beater fixed lead
and somebody's walking with
a lead extendable lead how do how do
they stand under this will they be fined
or how is that going to work
thank you chair and thank you councilor
phipps um so so clearly the important
thing
is that the
dog walker has the dog under control
and
to have that dog under control the lead
needs to be one meter and no more
and clearly if it's an extendable lead
if it's locked in position then that is
a fixed uh position and
and that that's fine so what we're
really looking for is highway safety
safety of dogs safety of pedestrians
and and of course also safety of car
drivers
because i think we've all seen dogs
shoot off on these extendable leads and
maybe in front of a car or something
like that so that that's what it's about
uh we're not about
handing out fines and the like we're
mostly about giving words of warning and
advice
counselor mcgregor
thank you chair it was just to remind
everybody that it's actually now a legal
requirement for all dogs to be on a
short fixed lead
when walking on any highway and that
includes paths lanes pavements and roads
that's a legal requirement it's not up
to us to to advise people on the length
of their lead or whether they have a
fixed or extendable one but when they're
walking along roads and payments it
makes sense for everybody to have a
fixed lead because that is a legal
requirement
councilman cancer folding
thank you can i just say that i think
this is really important especially in
sensitive areas
yesterday in dolish a black swan was
attacked and killed
by a dog
apparently it was on a fixed lease
but
nonetheless it's very upsetting for
residents of dawlish
and so that is the reason why i support
this but i'd like to
suggest that it also be included in
sensitive areas such as
well we've got the waterfowl thank you
thank you councillor vote and i'm sure
cancer dewhurst will make note of that
thank you
right it's been proposed by cancer juror
seconded by councillor foden can we go
to the vote in favor please
carried
against
no abstain no
okay fine we'll move on now to the next
item and i think with you again cancer
dewhurst it's a recommendation from
strata joint executive strata budget
[Music]
thank you very much chair yes it's
rather longer this time
but this is a recommendation that stems
from the strata joint executive
which met on wednesday the 19th of
january this year and i'm not going to
read the whole lot but basically it's
recommendation
that the following approved by east
devon district exeter city and cambridge
council
warned that the interim strata business
plan noting that a new version of the
strata business plan would be completed
and brought back for approval once these
three authorities had undertaken their
digital and i.t strategy work
and
agilisis
had completed their review of strata and
two the provision of power bi premium of
seventy thousand pounds
apportioned uh amongst the three
authorities as per the percentages in
the strata contract the total strata
services solutions limited budget of
7.37
million uh be apportioned
in the form of east devon district
council
2.866 million exeter city council 2.444
million and team bridge council 2.06
million and then finally the capital
requirements budget for the next 12
months
of a public switch telephone network
replacement for exeter city council of
40
uh exeter city council uh civic center
door access replacement of a hundred
thousand
system upgrade costs uh which is our
2012 server replacements that's a
hundred thousand pounds and apportioned
as 35
936 for exeter 36
692 for each devon and 27
372 for team bridge and then the
geographic information system cloud
migration 10 000 apportioned in the same
manner
so that would be
3594 for
exeter
3669
for east devon and 2737
for team bridge
thank you thank you council georges do i
have a second day for that please
control
mcgregor okay um anyone wishing to speak
i don't cancel russell
can you just hang on wait for them where
does strata live at the moment because
the second floor is like the murray
celeste
up there and um
it would be helpful to know where we can
find all these services that have been
relocated in the desert of what house at
the moment thank you
and the managing director answered that
one um
strata are operating mainly from home
but they have the
help desk is operating at the porter's
lodge so where the print really used to
be
so
yeah that is somewhere if you ring up
the help desk they're going to direct
you
if you need to drop a device off
yeah thank you very much as chairman of
the strata ons committee we didn't meet
at all no meeting was called so
this executive recommendation
hasn't been actually before the scrutiny
committee has gone on for some reason as
you know
we just heard that
strata is costing
7.37 million pounds
of which the team bridge share
is
2.2 million million
2.06
million is is what team bridge
the contribution is unfortunately we
seem to be locked into
a strata contract at the moment
but it's my belief that we're paying far
far too much money
uh
for our i.t provision
uh as an authority i did a piece of
scrutiny work
and asked the 151 officers that all the
district councils in devon how much they
were
were paying i think the the lowest
council
came back with a figure of under a
million and we're at
2.06 and
there we go um so but i appreciate that
we're locked into it this contract
whereby
there's uh
a considerable number of employees
over 70 i think are involved in strata
so that it's it's not something that
fits at all comfortably with me
and uh i just wanted to make that point
thank you very much
thank you counter clowns cancer connie
thanks chairman um i'm grateful for what
council's parents have said because
um
traditionally the three councils east
devon chambers and exeter recognized
that the i.t
services they were providing were very
fragile in terms of their capacity to
all the councils needed and it was the
decision of the three councils at the
time to set up strata which i think
councilor clarence supported um and in
that of course in that agreement
is a lock-in which when obviously
council clearance talks about not easy
to get out of there's a lock-in
for the three partner councils but as
part of that agreement obviously the
percentage apportionments were agreed
so i find it
interesting now that cancer currents
expresses concern about strata because
during the debate when council decided
to become part of strata i argued quite
intensely against strata against the
council doing it and he argued for it um
we are where we are with it and we have
to make the best of it i'm grateful to
uh councillor jewish for setting out in
that detail for us where we are and it's
good that that level of detail is here
and available in part one
but i think i'm going to resist council
parents rewriting some of the history we
are where we are because the council
took an informed decision at the time
which he supported others didn't but we
are and we accepted it and that's
democracy we have to make the best of it
thank you
thank you country hurst
different direction uh thank you chair
uh yes i'd just like to point uh
councillor clarence um in the direction
of item one um of this recommendation
and the fact that uh there is um a new
uh business strata business plan
being produced or already and will come
back for approval
once the three
authorities have
agreed it and also once the three
authorities have undertaken their own
digital and i.t strategy work and also
that aguilesis have completed their
review of strata because
we can all be great experts on these
kind of things
from from the comfort of in front of our
ipad
but this is a highly complex
company
dealing with three councils and a very
wide range of services that they offer
the three councils thank you
thank you very much right if no others
wishing to speak
we've been proposed by councillor jewehr
seconded by councillor mcgregor all
those in favor
against
abstain
okay we'll now move on with carried
uh and i think it's you again cancer jew
house item 14.
recommendations from strata joint
executive terms in terms of reference
thank you very much indeed uh chair so
um at that same meeting it was
recommended to east devon district uh
exeter city and team bridge council that
the stratas joint executive committee
terms of reference be amended to allow
for the office of representation to be
the chief executive or their nominee of
the three constituent authorities rather
than the chief executive
and of course uh chair that is in the
same way that the three leaders are
there or their nominated uh
appointee
thank you thank you very much that's
proposal for a secondary
second it count are you second
do we have a second here
again
cancer gone right cancer clearance
yes wait for the microphone very
interesting i didn't think we had a ce i
thought we now had a managing director
to
see he's going to this um
thing is he
to answer it wasn't for me it was forex
thank you very much right well that's
been proposed
and seconded can i go to the vote please
all those in favor
against
abstain
okay
that's carried
thank you
all right we'll move on to item 15 which
is
cycling and bylaws in newt nava an
executive member for planning councillor
to move this recommendation
thank you chair members
thank you chairman item 15 on today's
agenda is the proposal to amend the 1951
pleasure grounds bylaw wording regarding
cycle riding in the number of newton
albert parks
this proposed amendment which would be
subject to a wide-ranging qualitative
public consultation exercise would allow
cycles to be used within our parks
either where a right-of-way exists or on
designated routes for cycles
the suggested amended wording of the
existing bylaw can be found in appendix
d with the new text to paragraph 5b to
read a person shall not ride any bicycle
tricycle or other similar machine in any
part of the pleasure ground except in
any part of the ground where there is a
right-of-way for cycles or on a
designated route for cycles
plans for two of these designated
off-road cycle routes can be found in
the comprehensive cycling bylaw council
report that we have before us today
which has been prepared by our dedicated
green infrastructure officer and king
cycle rider estelle skinner who's cycled
over from tinder i believe today
cycling links such as those proposed by
bakers
but proposed for bakers park and
courtney park would only come forward
after careful consideration and where it
is useful
safe and locally appropriate
the importance of only dedicated schemes
coming forward is that this will ensure
proper provisions such as signage and
appropriate path width and surfacing can
be delivered together
the replacement of the bylaw would mean
that any properly considered dedicated
and secured scheme could come forward in
a permitted way
the bakers park scheme as detailed on
page 195 would form part of the ogwell
to newton abbott route
this is one of the priority devon county
council schemes and will provide an
option for bicycle riders to remain
off-road rather than to navigate the
busy and constrained top nest road that
presents a barrier to all but the most
confident cycle rider
this is a key link between ogwell and
west abbott and west newton albert
and the national cycle network via
newton abbott town centre and onwards
the link
via the eastern edge of courtney park as
shown on page 197
would be secured via the wider future
high street project delivery
the off-road cycle provision currently
terminates at newton-albert railway
station
this new scheme would include an upgrade
to the pedestrian crossing outside the
station to provide space to enable
bicycles also to cross safely
this short stretch of path via the
eastern edge of courtney park would
enable cycle rides riders to either join
queen street from courtney park road or
more advisably to continue via our
quieter back roads towards the town
centre as i did the other day and i
didn't get lost
chair members dedicated off-road routes
that provide logical and well-considered
connectivity will help reduce the risks
posed to those on bikes whose
alternative cycling options are to
remain on relatively busy and often
challenging roads around our district
the amendment proposed today will help
bring about such dedicated cycle routes
while at the same time helping fulfill
this council's core strategy and
environmental objectives
i would therefore be pleased to propose
the recommendations as set out on page
183
thank you catcher taylor do i have a
secondary for that please cancel connie
thank you very much
uh councilman mcgregor
thank you joe it was very interesting to
to hear that uh baker's park
is only coming forward if appropriate
when the cycle
route through the park um along the top
top lane was considered an integral part
of the the upgrade that was that was
carried out on the park um after uh
after the may elections in 2019
um so it is a bit of a surprise to find
out that's on the back burner and would
the
member for planning
please
enlighten us as to why it's gone from
being a priority to
an option
thank you
entertainer
certainly i'd be happy to respond it's
actually a devon county council scheme
but perhaps um our uh
officer who i say has cycled all the way
from timnuth to be here today would be
able to give give us some more uh
details on that subject
uh yep sure happy to uh happy to
elaborate um
the uh the scheme is a scheme that is
being taken forward through devon county
council um
with team bridge working in in
partnership
the
scheme has been progressing for some
time and
this is one of the elements that would
be needed in order to enable that scheme
to move forward
so
that would be one of the schemes that we
would we would like to see move forward
through this amendment to the bylaw
the funding
the majority of the funding that came
forward for the bakers park scheme
and came forward through section 106
funding
and devon county council have also put
some money towards
towards progressing that scheme
it's been put forward as a
desired scheme to enhance the linkage
for people living
on the edge of town to access into the
town and those town centre facilities
thank you very much finished before i
expected you
thank you very much happy with that
council mcgregor
thank you very much right so we've uh
had a proposal and secondary can we go
to the vote please
all those in favor
against
abstentions
and
that's carried
right now we could move on to item 16
which is
recommendation from pro
procedures notice of motion and i'll
just run through this myself as chair of
the committee
um it was following a notice of motion
submitted to this council by councillor
swain
and it was regarding um amendments to
the constitution
and he re it came back with a
recommendation from procedures that
in item 4.32 e public questions
the business of the meeting to be
amended to read the business of the
council
item two in section six schedule two row
two b3
minor amendments to the constitution to
add in after minor changes change which
no group leader
feels is significant in that it
fundamentally changes existing pro
provisions
and item three
to modify the constitution
to use gender neutral language
throughout to replace references to
chairman with chair
and he and his with they are there
so i so move that this be put forward um
can i have a second over that please
cancel the connect
okay
swain
councillors wayne
i do apologize council swing
okay uh everyone happy should we go to
the vote on that and to be accepted
or country mcgarry did you want to speak
thank you thank you chad i just want to
remind
the um
the council that at that meeting where
that was agreed councillor haines
obtained agreement from the that
committee
that um anybody who was
chair of the council or leader could
refer to themselves in their chosen
form
and that was agreed by the committee as
part of that motion
okay
thank you very much
right can we go to the vote then all
those in favor
against
abstentions
okay thank you very much i believe
that's carried
we'll now move on to item 17 which is
again procedures committee
right this was an item regarding public
and met members question times
and after discussion it was recommended
that we bring to full council the
timelines for submitting public and
member questions
to committee to be three clear working
days before the meeting
that's equalizing then between members
and members of the public
i.e should the meeting be on a thursday
the deadline would be on the friday
before at 5 pm so that's three clear
working days
prior
to the meeting
can i have a second of that please
cancel a hook
right no no mission to speak
can we go to the vote all those in favor
against
are you for and against cancer cox are
you
none against uh
abstentions
cancer mcgregor extension okay thank you
very much
if we can now go on to item 18 and this
is from canceler hook is a notice of
motion if you'd like to present this
cancer hook
thank you uh chair i've been waiting
since november to bring this
to the attention of the council um
my fault originally because i was about
an hour late for submitting it
to a previous full council before making
my speech however uh on what is an
incredibly important issue i believe i
am aware of the late hour i'm aware of
people having stayed well beyond and i
congratulate every single member who's
still here and i thank them for staying
particularly council mcgregor who's
carried on the role of opposition
which is very very important can i ask
that we debate the issue now and get rid
of it now
uh simply because
any delay will will negate the impact
that it may have and the importance of
getting this message out
before the the
the bill is enacted as an act of
parliament
so could i ask that we debate it now
please
well cancel hope we need two thirds of
the
other cancers here present to actually
agree to that uh can the cancers
indicate whether they'd be happy to do
that
i think it looks as if that is the case
okay
so that's
to grade counselor hook
then with mike up my nose
thank you um
mr chairman you and i have sat down from
time to time one to one and discuss
various things
i'd like to put it to everybody in this
room right now
that if we were to sit down face to face
you and i and i asked you certain
questions the first one of which would
be do you believe in democracy
do you believe in democracy
i hope sincerely that every single
person in this room would say yes
they'd say yes enthusiastically so
if we were to sit down and continue that
conversation one to one it might well be
that different interpretations of
democracy
would emerge we might have differences
for instance on how a vote
parliamentary level or any other level
will be taken there'd be those in favor
of first past the post and there'd be
those maybe who would like some
alternative method of voting but we all
agree that that voting in a free
election would be an aspect of a
democracy
i don't think it'd be anybody dissenting
to that
but if we look a bit further a bit
deeper a bit more uh substantive as to
what democracy means
i hope we could come up with some
constructive thinking
can i put it to every member every
person here that one of the absolute
fundamentals of
our democracy and of a democracy is the
right to opposition
the right
to protest
the right to say to a government or to
administration to this council you're
wrong
i don't agree
you're out of step
for whatever reason you're wrong
and that is a fundamental right i
believe of our democracy
that we as individuals have a right to
oppose and to say no
it varies around the world of course
goodness only knows we've got enough
examples recently of the way in which
democracy is either non-existent or has
been eroded
hitler's germany
south africa under apartheid
north korea
stalin's russia hey putin's russia lots
of different examples of where clearly
democracy is failed or failing or
non-existent
we in this country respect opposition
it's enshrined in our unwritten
constitution
we pay
the leader of the opposition in
parliament to lead opposition to the
government
i think all that's to be applauded and i
hope so far i've said nothing that
anybody can can
disagree with
the dictatorships that have
existed and still exist around the world
didn't emerge overnight
there were gradual steps in a downward
spiral of
suppression of minorities
and opposition to the government of the
day
i've been involved in protests most of
my life one way or another as a student
i led a uh a campus protest against the
vietnam war some of you were probably
born when the vietnam war was was going
on and um you can probably remember it
very few took notice and and even less
choiced in i must say it was a
depressing experience but it was a
protest i had the right to do it
i led a demonstration with with the with
pacquiao's
recently more rather more recently just
just before
covid uh set off
councillor jackie hook and and i went to
london and participated in a huge
uh climate change
demonstration
um it was a quiet fairly well organized
demonstration i think we both carried
banners i i did
um
and we we charted a bit
climate change what
we want action on climate change when we
want it now that sort of thing you
you've all seen it and heard it hundred
thousand people also fantastic
demonstration
if the legislation that is currently
before parliament
is enacted
i could be arrested
you could be arrested for taking part in
that demonstration
you could be arrested for chanting
that must be wrong
that has to be wrong
in recent years we've uh we've we've
seen protests of different sorts
when i was a county councillor we had a
protested cancer county from the i think
it was called wasp the women against the
raising of the pension agent and quite
right too and and they they took part in
a demonstration here in in town
are we going to stop them doing that and
or them risk becoming criminals
but that's the legislation that is
currently before parliament
the um
police and crime and whatever it is bill
it's it's been opposed by so many people
conservative members of parliament and
conservative peers have opposed this
legislation
350 organizations from around the
country have opposed this this
legislation
trade unions political parties pressure
groups friends of the earth
save save
the whale
no greenpeace lots of different
organizations trade unions churches
have opposed this legislation
and yet it's going through parliament
it's going through
despite
the fact
that quite a bit of it hasn't actually
been discussed in parliament
there are aspects of the bill which
have not even been raised in the house
of commons
let me just look at some of the other
aspects of the bill
clause 57 for instance
would give the police new powers to ban
public assemblies
not just protests but assemblies
meetings
they'll be unprecedented in unjustified
assault on the rights of freedom of
assembly and freedom of speech surely
the police will be given rights to stop
and search without reason
the only person who can define reason
will be currently pretty patel
or pretty ugly the home secretary
she is giving herself rights of
legal definition
these things must be wrong
they must be wrong
i
i i boris johnson's government is is
doing various things that are
anti-democratic and are destroying our
democracy one one legislation piece of
legislation going through at the moment
is the the elections bill which will
actually prevent tens of thousands of
people almost certainly from having the
right to vote
must be wrong i'm not dealing with the
elections bill right now i'm dealing
with the police and crime
uh legislation the draconian bill
includes awful and unnecessary new laws
to crack down on the fundamental british
right to peaceful assembly and protest
they are part of the conservative
government's anti-democratic attempts to
silence any opposition to its policies
we are on a slippery slope
we are on a slippery slope
and uh i will i won't detain members any
longer than necessary
the police don't want this legislation
former police and crime commissioners
have opposed it
and the police themselves believe they
currently have sufficient powers
we've had a
a cultural debate this afternoon a long
and lengthy culture of debate i'm going
to add to it for two minutes one minute
i bear with me this the last thing i
want to say before asking you to support
the notice of motion i have um in front
of you and i won't read that again you
can you've all got it there but
first they came for the communists
and i didn't speak out
because i was not a communist
then they came to the socialists
now i didn't speak out because i i
wasn't a socialist
then they came
to the trade unionists
and i didn't speak out because i'm not a
trade unionist then they came for the
jews
and i didn't speak out because i'm not a
jew
then they came for me
and there was no one left
to speak out for me
because they eroded our democracy don't
let them do it
don't let them do it
i move
the notice emotion i set out thank you
thank you councillor cox council
mcgregor you wanted to come in
yes thank thank you councillor hook that
was a very moving speech and i'm fully
supportive of your motion without
question
and um i'm glad that you pointed out
that uh the importance of
uh opposition and being able to to
oppose and question and and
simply ask for detail really um because
you know sometimes we we find that um
you know if we take a couple of
instances even today there was there
were attempts to to close down debate
and it's quite important that's not you
chair by the way just so you know it's
not into you um
but it's really important that we we act
consistently ourselves in this chamber
as well as
seeking to protect from or seeking
protection from above from from uh
democratic structures above us and
oppose laws that erode
and debilitate our ability to
um
to to be up in opposition and to protest
and to question thank you very much
thank you councilman
well i think we're generally in support
council hook i think councillor [ __ ]
moved that we uh go to the vote on that
you're quite happy with that anyone else
want to comment
all those in favor
against
abstentions
no
no council occurrence is abstaining and
cancer appeared is abstaining
okay
i had cancer russell didn't see your
hand cancer russell
i think that that's carried
okay thank you very much that will be
done
now we move to the final item which is
canceller questions um
and these are
counters from i think we've got six
questions
and the first one is from councillor
wrigley have you a supplementary
councillor wrigley
i have i thank you and i thank the lead
of his response
and my supplementary question is
so for the avoidance of doubt
given the process to determine public
speaking at planning committee does not
operate on a first come first served
basis
could fake objectors registering to
speak early be automatically selected
ahead of genuine community
representatives who register later
cancer connor
no
right
okay
um yes
and the next one please counselor hugh
cox
no supplementary that's fine
uh councillor andrew swain
supplementary
thank you thank you for the detailed
explanation so in fact in this case the
officer did far more than was required
to help objectors after they failed to
register to speak by the deadline if the
rules had been followed exactly to the
letter no one would have been able to
speak to oppose at all
would you join me in thanking the
officers for the excellent job that they
did and do often in very difficult
circumstances
when you come to swain county
yes
[Music]
okay
follow that counselor clarence you have
three questions have you supplementaries
for your first one
yes indeed
microphone please yes indeed you'll see
i asked the leader and to confirm
through his legal team
that we weren't complicit uh in granting
planning outcry
planning applications that were could
well be construed to be causing further
public nuisance
uh the
the first response didn't seem to answer
the question at all
um
it just talked about
uh
self
risk or something so my question is why
won't he really answer the question
instead of pontificate
okay that's council taylor
over there please
hand up gary
i believe i did answer the question i'm
not in the uh
i'm not usually one to pontificate
okay thank you
second question cancer clearance
supplementary
wait for the
microphone uh i i
i'm not in the habit of being uh called
uh misguided when it comes to the
tortoise rule of rylands versus fletcher
uh this was a an event where a dam burst
and uh
the person was liable even in the
absence of negligence so
my
legal
uh person that i asked upon this
is completely uh shall we say at odds
with the the response that i got when i
was misleading so i don't accept that a
question uh
and would i ask the member for planning
as my supplementary question
um is he still persisting with this
answer
cancer taylor right beside you
um
i
yes is the answer to that question
i i
law myself but
i am advised that uh what you've stated
uh is incorrect
okay
final question counselor clarence
supplementary
uh yeah my final question as you
probably saw
um
which the answer
uh was given uh i was purely seeking a
betterment plan and trying to
mark the southwest waters card as to the
number of stress discharges
and uh
i find the the answer that given was
absolutely flabbergasted really when
it was quoted if you look at the the
answer here uh no cause for concern uh
about these discharges
that have been made in stress discharges
no cause for concern uh was made by
either the southwest water or the ea
so
you know
we are the ones that are actually
signing off the planning permissions
there and therefore i still maintain
that we are the ones culpable for
causing a public nuisance
anyway you know
that that is my my question to you do
you still persist in the answer that
you've given me and why
can't this authority
start marking southwest waters card as
to the amount of discharges that we're
getting is is completely unacceptable
um well in many ways i do agree uh with
councillor clarence
on what he says but it is it's not true
to say that we that the authority have
the responsibility it's the environment
agency
who do
monitor uh southwest ward waters
discharges under storm conditions
just as a just as a point of course
that having looked at some of the
numbers 1.1 billion pounds has been
promised to be spent in terms of
reducing
storm overflows over the next five years
in comparison uh to that 1.1 billion
over five years one
17 billion pounds has been spent in
dividends in the last 12 years
by by the by the water companies so i
think that shows where uh where um
a lot of this money is going it's going
to dividends instead of going into uh
fixing the problem and
and and that lies at the root of why
we're why we've got the problem that we
have thank you
thank you uh cancer taylor i do believe
that brings us to the end of the meeting
thank you very much to those of you who
remain can you stay seated until the
live stream is finished i just would
like to say thank you to everyone
connected with a meeting a long and
contentious interesting meeting and
thank all the officers for all the work
they've done in preparation and here
today
especially sarah
thank you very much